e
e e
okay it's 10: a.m. uh representative
Newsome you want to lead us in the
pledge
okay all right let's get going going to
open up the public hearing where is my
gavl there we go I'm going to open up
the public hearing for the house
election law committee for House Bill uh
7eleven FN relative to voting machine
contractors going to recognize
representative Bernardi uh for the
purpose of
introduction representative Bernard I
don't think we've seen you this year
welcome to election law
thank you very much chair sorry I'm I'm
gonna pause representative Bernardi
before we get going my apologies I need
to do my normal disclaimer uh we're on
our uh standard five minute introduction
clock two-minute public speaking uh time
um so there you go representative right
now you're up again I
apologize uh I have no control over
those mics I can move my mouth closer
and talk louder but I can't do anything
else again thank you chair and election
law committee for the record my name is
represent JD bernardy Rockingham 36 with
Hampton Falls Kensington Southampton
Newton and plastow so I'm here to
introduce House Bill 711 in act relative
to voting machine contractors what this
bill does is very simple requires
contractors who repair voting machines
to register with the secretary of state
and the attorney general and obtain and
in in that process obtain a registration
number they will get in order to present
proof of bonding and
insurance uh and it also permits them to
obtain a contractor
ID prior to working on or accessing any
voting machine that these contractors
are to present to the local official uh
that photo ID with the name the
company's name the registration number
and then have that ID visibly available
at all times the local official will
record that information on the device
log the bill requires the Secretary of
State to provide training on all these
measures it should be very D Minimus
simple addition to their current
procedural
manual um but I will make one comment
here assuming you accept this bill I
would ask you to make an an
amendment uh when I was working with OLS
they did not change
the Attorney General uh to the
Department of
Insurance the uh insurance and bonding
activities that are
required uh are done by the insurance
department and the enforcement unit
thereof so it the AG is inappropriately
called out in this bill it should be the
insurance department in order to take
care of the the bonding and insurance
and any um Associated enforcement which
is all part of their daily
activity uh the rationale for the bill
is simple this this is a election
Integrity uh concern bonding ensures a
contractor will be vetted by the shity
company and can be can be considered
reliable enhances the likelihood of the
work's going to be completed as required
and protecting against any any
substantial or faulty work um so with
that I'm happy to answer any questions
from the committee are there questions
from the committee representative L you
recognized um thank you and thank you
for taking my question um is is this not
done now by the SOS I Secretary of State
do you know no okay and follow up okay I
follow yep of course just got to do my
procedure I just
um I guess it seems like
a and I don't know maybe I wait till
Secor say I wondered if there's the same
contractor for all the machines if you
if you know whether or not that's the
case well up until recently we only had
one class of machines so the contractors
working on them would be all from one
company now there's two classes of
machines so I would expect there would
be different
contractors further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is Wayne SAA from
Nashua represent Bay you can take your C
if you want it's not big deal oh you're
one around oh oh you're going to sit
over there
today doesn't she nor me to sit over
there am I am I losing my
mind okay am I
losing okay sorry I I guys can't be
doing that to
me welcome I got to press the button one
more time until it lights are up red yep
red is good there you go obviously I'm
not Wayne seya he was unable to get here
there's been a number of accidents is it
okay that I read his testimony and I can
also leave it on the desk uh that that's
fine just we got to keep it under two
minutes so no no I know that from last
time okay uh testimony of Wayne P seya
senior I am voting in the affirmative to
approve HB 711 but only with the with an
addition to the existing Bill to include
the following language or words
resulting in the same action I quote
where New Hampshire is an OSHA State any
and all elect elic voting machine
contractors shall maintain all OSHA
safety certification requirements for
all electronic voting machines for the
safety and protection of New Hampshire
election officials and staff end quote
on September 7th 2021 I submitted an
expert witness preliminary report my
report in the case of Richard versus
sununu my report unfortunately exposed a
number of both state and federal
violations that the majority if not all
existing electronic tabulating voting
machines currently possess my conclusion
read I recommend New Hampshire cease
using all ACU vote machines and any
other electronic tabulating voting
system or device experiencing the same
maintenance and operation currently New
Hampshire does not have a federally
approved and required state plan which
is at least as effective as the federal
OSHA regulations this would include
safety certification for all electronic
devices and systems used by the public
and private workers if this were not
true all Antiquated and modified
machines would not be legally permitted
in use today to my dismay that I report
to this committee that all Antiquated
and modified electronic voting machines
in this state have been and are
currently used unlawfully as outlined in
my September
report uh and he just unders sworn to
pains and penalties and I have his
report for
you okay thank you will you be taking
questions from the committee I'll try
Okay are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you uh next up is Al
brandano from
Kensington welcome to election
law yep so we put that we new policy
this year we put every unless it's uh is
this copies of your written testimony or
is this a document you need Rel that
you're going to be
referencing okay document can be
referenced as can be distributed um but
if it's a copy of your testimony it just
goes in the center
oh Al brand Deno from Kensington New
Hampshire um first of all this is common
sense when you think about it I'm a
youth H hockey coach um and a high
school hockey coach in the past and I
have to have a background check if
you're a kidgoten teacher or you run
anything you have a background check
this is common sense that people are
working on our machines and we really
don't know who they
are and what I did is I gave you an
example of this first of all this is all
part of the Senate District 24 uh review
from April 5th 2023 that um
unfortunately this body elected not to
move forward
with um so here's just a simple example
of over
150 uh we have activity logs which are
uh affidavits if you look at the bottom
of the a the of the activity log it's an
actual affidavit it's an RSA and an
affidavit and you'll find uh and not
only places where people are not
witnessed a second witness was is
required by law but you'll find that
when someone does a repair on a machine
it says repair and you can't read the
person's name
now why is that important believe it or
not because I live in Kensington I
looked at the contract for LHS LHS can
hire subcontractors to work on machines
they don't all all necessarily have to
have a contractor their contractor it
could be a subcontractor according to
their contracts and I'm sure with a new
machine company that's joined the same
um and once again you'll see it here in
the next one just kind of pointing it
out one the affidavits aren't properly
executed Ed and two uh maintenance on
the machines we don't know who that
person is nor does the town clerk uh
unless they have a certified badge
number or it's recorded somewhere on
this so citizens know who worked on
their machines um it's basic Integrity
um and I'll take any questions are
questions from the
committee sigan thank you uh next up
is is Lyn Briggs
welcome
back long time no
see Lyn Briggs amris New
Hampshire uh I am a government approved
election staff person which is a ballot
Clerk and that is officially approved by
the government for both the town and
state primary and full elections I need
my glasses my complaint is that the
safety and efficacy of these Dominion
ACU votee machines they were not voted
on number one by We the People the state
bought from and hired LHS to maintain
all these machines and the memory cards
and to note that officially LHS was
never certified by Dominion who H who
owns and sells the machines these
machines were knowingly modified there
is a directive by the Secretary of State
to cut the wires I'll keep it Street
Talk per the directive of himself
scandin further evidenced by the
testimony in 2021 at Rockingham Superior
Court further evidenced by by there's a
book by the results of Windom recount
and there's snapshots and screenshots of
the actual cutting of these wires in the
machines there has also been several
instances in marac uh nasua where they
take parts from other machines and put
them into the current machines which
therefore therefore nullifies the
certification by modifying these
machines the accuracy of the vote tally
cannot be validated there are also
unknown unforeseen medical issues
further these ACU vote machines have not
been safety certified since the first
maintenance Andor part replacement this
is Decades of not being safety certified
New Hampshire is an OSHA State thank you
and I do have which I won't go into
right now but um in going through the
records in Amherst I can show that a
clock chip on the same machine was
changed two months in a row I have
invoices showing the maintenance they
don't have signatures um I also have
information from a recount an official
recount that shows the problems with the
machines and I have the facts uh of the
case of the law from that we sent to
OSHA if that would help sure um and it
doesn't think you have 20 copies of that
so I assume that it's going to go to the
clerk for as part of your
testimony uh or I can just leave this
with you that's what I'm saying you
would go to the clerk oh okay yeah yeah
we're saying the same thing okay yeah
you don't have copies for distribution
you just have copies no no no no no
doing this last second yep totally fine
yep um
yeah I assuming you're taking questions
M
BRS and thank you for taking the
questions um you indicated that the
accuracy cannot be verified um I mean we
have numerous recounts and audits of
these machines I guess I'm a little
confused by your statement so the
accuracy um because they have been
modified because Parts have been
replaced from the point of view from
OSHA that anything that has not been
safety re safety C ified you cannot
verify the accuracy just from that point
of Maintenance in the actual
machine further
questions sing Oh yes have
representative PR O'Brien thank you Mr
chairman are you're talking also about
safety for people using these machines
but these are not Machine Tools I'm not
I'm a little confused about why there's
the OSHA connection I guess you just
covered that OSHA connection but could
you talk about why you're concerned
about operator
safety um that's not my area of
expertise I have talked about it before
that is actually Mr Wayne say it that
would be someone you'd want to speak to
but it is my understanding because once
you have um uh modified the machines we
cannot tell what is going on with it we
can't tell if it's putting out any kind
of electronic pulses or anything like
that and that was the point of view that
was brought up at another meeting but
that's his area of expertise further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you thank you uh last up is Sarah
Burke
Cohen from the New Hampshire missal
Association although it looks like we're
about to have a late
entry good morning my name is Sarah
Burke Cohen I am from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association I am here to speak
to you as we oppose this bill um we
oppose this bill because uh there is for
the municipalities there seems to be um
either some confusion on um you know
who's a designated Municipal uh official
who photographic identification is
presented to um you know how does the
registration process work how does the
municipality ensure that the
registration number is valid or not
expired um so the municipal Association
opposes this um in terms of there seems
to be some ambiguity in this bill still
um when it comes uh to municipalities
and how they are supposed to process
this I'll take questions questions from
the committee represent of
Lane thank you um you may not know the
answer to this but I'm gonna ask um who
asks for the machines to be fixed is
that the towns and the cities the
municipalities or or do they and do they
work with um secretary of state so
that's actually two questions sorry I'm
not entirely sure but I can look into
that and I think that there may be some
testimony on that in a few minutes that
can maybe go into some greater detail
relative to the
machines questions from the committee
further questions seeing none thank you
um last up is uh deputy secretary of
state Aon Hennessy representative
gasowski can you grab the blue sheet for
me
good morning everyone Aaron Hennessy
deputy secretary of state thank you Mr
chair I am happy to answer any questions
you have but first I just want to go
over a few um language concerns I have
with the bill um first um we have
currently we have two vendors in the
state we use the term vendor um so if
you would like to use the word
contractor we would like that to be
defined by exactly what you mean by that
do you mean the um company the vendor of
the electronic ballot counting devices
or do you mean somebody who maybe um the
town clerk has called in to do something
separate from what they who they've um
who the vendor is for the device that
they've purchased it from um so please
define the word vendor I'm contractor
excuse me also um we're unclear about
what the bond is for who you're bonding
if you're bonding the individual who's
working on the equipment or if you're
bonding the um the company who has um
distributed that equipment who the town
or city has purchased the equipment from
we are not involved in the purchasing uh
of the devices each um individual town
or city purchases the devices themselves
from the two vendors in the state
currently we have three devices that can
be purchased um these devices are
authorized by the ballot law commission
from New Hampshire and um they are l and
voting works and I am not aware that
they use any subcontractors to do any
work on the devices themselves they um
they themselves do the work if it's
maintenance on a um ball counting device
or if something goes wrong um during the
testing of the device uh the city or
town clerk will call the vendor and the
vendor will either troubleshoot it over
the phone or show up in
person we also don't know um who is
going to be respons responsible for
making the photo IDs to my knowledge I
don't think that these vendors have
photo IDs for their employees um and how
will the city or town clerk know that
that is an authorized photo ID I think
the municipal Association spoke to that
briefly um I think those are what the
clarifications that we would need I'm
happy to take any questions questions
from the
committee representative where thank you
Mr chair and thank you deputy secretary
for taking my question the um I believe
the voting works as the open source
software and therefore has capability of
programming by people other
than
um the cont the vendor um is is that a
correct statement or is thank you for
the question um you are correct that
they have open- Source software but that
doesn't mean that it is open source to
everyone um the vendor uh is voting
works and they are the company that the
clerk would reach out to if there was a
an issue with the device themselves and
they are the vendor that would update
the software if a new version is
approved by a battle law commission but
anyone can look at that coding and if
they can understand coding they can
understand it but it's not open to
external
coding further questions from the
committee representative where your
followup yes thank you Mr chair um I'm
recalling this from memory so it it
could be very faulty but the it was my
understanding that there was uh
extensible markup language that they
were using for programming the voting
Works machines and that that there was I
thought when they appeared before the
ballot law commission they talked about
having capabilities to have local
programming but I I I could be wrong so
I I'm I'm just curious if you remember
anything about that thank thank you for
the question and I think you're
referring to that if
um if they have a voting Works device
and they um they've bought the option to
do it local clerks can um design their
ballots for their local elections but
they are just importing the candidates
names and the questions they're not
programming the functioning of the
device and I'm not I'm not an IT
person further questions from the
committee represent
Gilmer thank you Mr chair morning Aaron
um are you aware of any incident over
the last 30 years of um necessitating
this
legislation thank you for the question I
have not heard of anything um of a a
rogue contractor but I'm happy to look
into it
um thank you yeah further questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you um does
anyone else wish to speak to this bill
seeing none um there was no one signed
up on the blue sheet and online 711 had
29 in support seven opposed with that
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 711 going to open the public
hearing on House Bill
270 uh requiring the preservation of
electronic counting
um device memory chips and now recognize
our clerk who
for the purpose of introduction she's
the only card so members should stand
ready for executive session assuming it
doesn't go very
long thank you Mr chairman and fellow
committee
members um repres resentative Claudine
Burnham representing straford District 2
Milton Rochester w 5 I'm introducing HB
270 a bill requiring the preservation of
electronic ballot counting device memory
chips just like we preserve all ballots
absentee ballot applications affidavit
envelopes and lists we believe that the
memory cards that hold all information
from the ballot device should also be
held until all contests are settled
appeals have been expired and at least
22 months after the election for federal
and non-federal elections these devices
are very important in our election
process and should be preserved and
treated as important as the ballots
applications and lists thank you for
considering considering and ought to
pass so our voters can feel that the
memory cards are safe and secure and
available should an audit be necessary
thank you questions from the committee
represent
L same to be the question lady today
thanks for taking my question
um it's a very um I'm just a little
confused because we talk about memory
chips but then in the text of the bill
it talks about memory cards and I am by
no means a technological whiz but I'm
just curious is memory cards are we
confident that that's capturing like all
the different Technologies and I'm
thinking USBS I'm thinking is it on a
hard drive so that's my question very
good question thank you um so it is the
card that actually is inserted in the
machine the title put chips I'm not sure
why but it is referring to the memory
cards and that's what I related to in my
my testimony where I should have had
cards instead it's just the little
device that goes in versus going
straight back to the um Secretary of
State's office after elections or to
whoever it goes to I don't know if it's
to the SEC AR of state or if it's to
the um location of the
vendor further questions on the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up is deputy secretary of state Aaron
Hennessy and um without objection
representative burn will be allowed to
rejoin so she can do her D dut Duty as
clerk thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Aon Hennessy deputy secretary
of state um thank you representative you
have my question I just want to clarify
that this would be based on the
sponsor's testimony that this would
refer to the external memory sticks or
external memory drives or whatever um
language you want to call it and not an
internal um piece of equipment that goes
into a um electronic balla County device
um currently the uh voting Works device
after an election we do train all
election officials to securely store
these devices with their ballots so they
are maintained um the um New Image cast
uh will be used in one maybe two March
Town elections that has been
conditionally approved by the ballot law
commission and we will be also training
these towns to store these as well I
would ask for an exemption from this um
I'm not sure when the acote devices will
go out of use in the state of New
Hampshire
but as the um sponsor
noted these are um I'm not quite sure
what exactly the industry would call the
cards the memory cards that are used for
these devices but they are recycled um
and reused for each election and so they
have to go back to the vendor to be
reprogrammed for another election and
unfortunately because the device is so
old and with the lack of supply for
these um if we were to store them with
the ballots they would not be able to be
programmed for a future election and
there would be supply
issues will you be taking questions
repes uh representative deputy secretary
Hennessy my apologies will you be taking
questions yes um representative mad
thank you Mr chair thank you
um would the right takeaway be that that
we that with respect to the new machines
did you call them image cast there two
voting works
yeah okay with the respect to the new
machines
um that this bill would just codify what
we already do would that be the a fair
interpretation that's correct yep
further question from the committee
seeing none thank you last up is Alber
andano from Kensington um representative
gusowski if you grab that uh sheet for
me please thank
you 270
uh thank you Mr chair my name is Albert
andano I'm from Kensington New Hampshire
um the most important part of this bill
is the strict chain of custody um if you
look at Hava the America uh to build
trust in our elections we have to have
an accurate compliant securable and
auditable
election what you heard from the
Secretary of State's um assistant is
incorrect because you are violating
currently violating federal law and the
state has been noticed of this I will
point out uh the app appal Constitution
and statutory provisions and I'll leave
it with you up top here uh it's 42 USC
20701 retention and preservation of
records and papers by officers of
Elections deposited with a custodian and
the penalty of violation the next one is
42 USC
20702 thft D thft theft excuse me
destruction concealment mutilation or
alteration of records and papers and
penalties and third 44 us code 3301
3301 definition of electronic
records I'll submit this to you um this
has been going on for a long time these
records are supposed to be held for 22
months and we're in violation we're in
violation because we may we have a
contractor who has a problem with memory
cards that's not this body's qu that's
not this body's issue we're to follow
the law and if the law says what it does
we're not to why would we take a knee to
A administrative or a corporation that's
selling us products that we're breaking
the law
for will you be taking questions yes I
will are there questions from the
committee seean thank you um I don't
have any other pink cards um there was
no one signed up on the blue sheet
online there was 24 in support and 94
posed but I wouldn't read into that
because one of them says Be Kind to all
God's creatures and two of them talk
about floride so I don't think uh I
think I think there may have been some
confusion with people giving testimony
um so do your best do your best with
those
numbers because it's pretty funny um
anyways um I'm going to close the public
hearing for uh House Bill 270 we're
going to go into our noticed executive
session so going to open up the
executive session for the house election
law committee um we're going to start
off with uh house bill I don't have the
title excuse me um house Bill
472 let me read the title my apologies
uh requiring voters to prove domicile
and representative Wei is recognized for
a motion I'd like to make a motion thank
you Mr chair I'd like to make a motion
that we itl is there a second I'll
second representative Lane second is
there discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
uh Mr chair yeah yes um uh just uh very
briefly um while the bill proposed Bill
had some uh good uh aspects to consider
for tracking domicile it was really
um uh checking the domicile credentials
during uh the check-in process as
opposed to during the registration
process and for that reason the
subcommittee decided that it was
appropriate to itl the bill um for that
reason thank you further discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
um I will note that the bill was
unanimous out of the subcommittee for
motion of inex speeding to legislate um
oh and I I'm I'm sorry I didn't do my
standard representative Lane this was
unannounced executive session are you
okay with us executing this Bill yes
okay thank you um all right is there any
further discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legisla House Bill
472 are you ready for the question L
clerk will call the role
representative qua yes representative
Kar Ryan Yes representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey
Balia yes representative C yes
representative gzowski
yes sorry representative toner yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes
oh that's why sorry she's coming back
she's coming back I'm coming oh Gil
representative Gilmore yes sorry I
crossed out my my glasses are messing
with the lines my apologies um
representative wilham yes representative
Nome yes who did I miss oh you are oh
yes and chair Barry the chair votes yes
sorry uh with that the motion of
inexpedient to House Bill 472 carries on
a vote of 17 to Z um write down that 17
to Z because I'll mess that up later um
is there any objection to this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
hearing none the bill will be placed on
a consent calendar I'm going to close
the executive session for House Bill
472 going to open up the EXE the notice
executive session for House Bill 141
relative to
campaign excuse me um relative to
campaign disclosures for limited
liability companies and I'm going to
recognize representative wood for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
recommend HB 141 to move itl
representative wood moves in expedient
to legislate on House Bill 141 is there
a second second representative gasowski
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to
legislate repres representative Lane
you're
recognized um thank you um again I would
just say what I said when I introduced
the bill this is about transparent Arcy
and it's not saying that limited
liability companies cannot give money
it's just that you want to be
transparent about how they do it the
same standard that we hold for
individuals and for
corporations so further discussion on
the motion of in expedience to legisl on
House Bill 141 are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the
role representative quaale yes
representative P O Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane
no representative Ward
no representative Gilmore no
representative
mayhead said oh I'm sorry representative
Bay
no Representative wilham no
representative Nome
no and chair rry chair votes yes and
with that the motion of any speak to
legislate carries on a vote uh for any
speak to legislate on house but 141
carries on a vote of 10 to 7 uh
representative wood you will be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane will you be
responsible for the Minority Report
excellent with that I'm going to close
the executive session for House Bill 141
um we're going to come back to 158 CU we
may actually get to talk about it um I'm
going to open the uh the noticed
executive session for House Bill
172 uh restricting Undeclared voters
from same day voting in presidential
primaries or state primary I recognize
myself I'll make a motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 172 is there
a second representative well we'll take
representative Ward we'll make it
bipartisan today or representative
wilham you want on this one we'll all
get on it um
I I I'm I'm going to apologize to the
committee in advance because normally
you guys know I like to power through
these execs but I do want to talk about
this real fast um because it's mostly my
party that has brought this forward and
I just kind of want to address concerns
from con from Wings F factions of my
party that's brought this forward this
is honestly much to do about nothing um
the semios primier that we have um yes
there are Bad actors in it and shame on
those Bad actors the the Bad actors
being people Undeclared voters who lean
One Direction and then vote in the other
directions part primary with the
intention of messing with it those
people exist they shouldn't be doing
what they're doing um I would hope we
would all agree with that that you
should be voting in the primary that you
most align with um however um because
those Bad actors do those things it
breeds this idea that we should shut out
all Undeclared voters so I actually did
something that no one has done before
which actually went into the numbers and
see how how many of these Bad actors
could we readily identify so in the the
most coordinated effort we've seen for
quote unquote Bad actors in a primary
was actually in the latest 2024
presidential primary where supporters of
one of the presidential campaigns uh
actively went out and recruited left
leaning Undeclared voters to vote in the
Republican primary they actively did
that there's no doubt about it I have
the receipts they were they they were
doing it they were doing it so what I
did was I said okay how many those
people how many of those Undeclared
voters voted in the Republican
presidential primary and then came and
voted in the Democrat State primary so
same year both sides right and I I
assume it's not a true assumption but I
assume that they're all Bad actors
they're probably not but just for the
sake of this let's assume that they are
so if they if you assume all of those
people there was 316,400
out of those people
23,000 uh 95 voted in the Republican
presidential primary and then voted in
the Democrat State primary or 7.3% of
the overall vote so 7.3% of the overall
vote in the Republican primary came from
people that could be labeled Bad actors
which means 92 93% were probably voting
with who they aligned with and that's
assuming that all those people are Bad
actors which is not a fair assumption
but I'm just going to do it anyways um
if you further dive down in the numbers
you say all right how many of those were
just Undeclared so how many of the
Undeclared are Bad actors in that
situation so there were
13654 Undeclared voters in the
Republican 2024 presidential primary so
of that as I said the 23,095 um that
would make them 17 16.9 91% or let's
call it 177% of the Undeclared voters in
the most
coordinated I don't want to say attack
but let's say the most coordinated
effort to undermine a Party primary um
so for us to eject all all Undeclared
voters from our primary would be
ejecting 80% to go after potentially 20%
so you lose four good voters to try to
get one to try to get one bad voter it's
just bad math um so when you see these
things you know people shouldn't be bad
actors they are there are Bad actors
they shouldn't be doing it because it
leads to legislation like this but the
fact of the matter is even the most
coordinated attack was really only 7.3%
of the vote so you know there's the
philosophical reasons to oppose this um
the one for me is that um you shouldn't
be asking the taxpayers to fund an
election that they can't participate in
um so that's my philosophical objection
to it but if you actually want to go
into what impact are the Bad actors
having um it's arguably minimal and I
would say that in the most coordinated
well funded attack ever Donald Trump
still won the Primary so even when they
tried really really hard and they had
nothing on the other side to draw them
over they still failed so let's not
eject 80% of Voters of Undeclared voters
to go after the 20% it's bad it's bad
math um and I'm glad that we're going
probably going to universally iil this
but anyways I'm sorry to derail the
executive session but I felt those
numbers needed to be said um and I felt
that that needed to be said out loud and
I'm willing to take the heat for it so
with that does anyone else wish to aine
are you ready for the question of the
motion of expedient to legislate on
House Bill
172 the clerk will call the
role representative quy yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative
C yes representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes chair Barry
chair votes yes without the motion of
any expedient to legislate on House Bill
172 carries on a vote of 17 to zero is
there any objection this bill being
placed on consent calendar hearing none
the bill will be placed on consent
calendar I will be responsible for the
report in which you'll see a lot of
those same numbers again with that I
will close the executive session for
House Bill 172 and we are going to go
back into a stance of public hearing so
we're going to open open up the public
hearing for House Bill
341 FN requiring the Secretary of State
to check voter records prior to every
election and we are going to recognize
our own representative Ward for the
purpose of
introduction thank thank you chairman
Barry I appreciate that nice to see you
all out here from a different
perspective uh my name is Jerry Ward and
I represent excuse me Rockingham 27
which is Ward 4 in Portsmouth and as I
get going I should note that the tagline
analysis for this bill is not exactly
what the bill is about which we've seen
on
occasion uh I was asked to bring forward
this bill HB 341 FN by the six member
Board of registrars of the city of
Portsmith to make a small change to the
law that will improve their work and
make our voter lists more accurate while
respecting the rights of Voters in the
interest of full disclosure as some of
you know my wife Barbara is the registar
at large and supervisor of the checklist
in Portsmouth but this bill has the
support of her entire board and I
suspect of registrars in other cities as
well who experienced the same issue in
2024 that prompted this dare I say
simple bill
this bill is designed to guarantee a
reasonable time at least 90 days for
supervisors of the checklist registar of
Voters and City Clerks to complete the
process of removing voters from the
checklist based on the national change
of address
NCA list provided by the United States
Postal Service through the good offices
of the Secretary of State moving the
date of receipt to at least 90 days
prior to any election will ensure that
it will be received well before any
deadline for verification of the
checklists excuse me and prior to the
deadline for submitting absentee ballot
requests and so on in 2024 the
registrars in psmith and elsewhere were
caught short uh when they received the
ncoa list for review only on August 28th
just before the Labor Day weekend and
only 13 days before the state primary at
a time when they were still processing
hundreds of voter registrations and some
absentee ballots had already been
returned getting the NCA letter at such
a late date for whatever reason uh with
a thousand names on it or so created an
unfortunate situation that was
detrimental to their work and to the
rights of some voters it is possible for
the registrars to receive the NCA list
from the Secretary of State's office in
a more timely fashion in 2023 for
example they received the lists on June
30th in a year when there were only
Municipal elections uh and thus had
about four months to review the lists
and notify votes voters an ample time to
contact any voters who they belied
should not be removed without going
through the 30-day letter process the
NCA
lists uh include people who've simply
changed their address to a post office
box uh that is more convenient for them
but who have not actually moved from the
domicile address at which they are
registered to vote uh who have temp or
who have temporarily changed their
address because of seasonal moves and
the NCA lists also include some people
who are OV voters evaluating such
changes and address carefully takes time
and requires some caution I think we all
recognize that the NCA lists are a very
valuable tool but Al although they're
mostly accurate like everything they are
not necessarily completely so and each
voter's circumstances need to be
evaluated
individually so I believe that this
small change to the pertinent RSA 654
col 45 would provide ample time for
proper review of NC away lists by our
supervisors and registrars primary uh
prior to primary General Municipal and
town elections I don't believe it should
cause the Secretary of State's office
any undue issues uh and it will enhance
the maintenance and accuracy of voter
list that we all want while respecting
the rights of all voters thank
you will you taking questions anybody
else signed up uh deputy secretary is
why not let her answer you probably well
GL did yes I was going to say if you
don't take questions your ranking member
is going to want to talk to you cuz I
was talked to representative weie uh
assuming that time machines have not
been invented yet would you want to
change the date on line three from July
1st 2022 to maybe
202 five or 2026 or something like that
you may not make it exp poost
facto yeah perhaps good idea using fancy
Latin language on me right there's thank
you for the question and there's some
good uh there's a some other language
changes we might put in there too uh
online but I you no that's a good point
and yeah do a followup representative
wearing thank you Mr chair and I
just uh you you mentioned that
um I think doing this um annually in
this manner will
also make ultimately the work easier for
those
uh supervisors of the checklist is that
the general consensus yes sir thank you
further questions on the committee
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um this is annually
is uh is that implying it's done once a
year because we have elections that are
more than 90 days
apart I think it's thank you for the
question good question I think it means
90 days before any election
would you like a followup or SC followup
okay uh okay so it's it's for any
election not just
annually maybe the word annually is not
the best word then thank you sounds like
we need some amending to what could be a
bipartisan bill could be we'll see
represent represented in your head sorry
Qui question on the previous question
thank you Mr chair I me as I understood
the word and I'd like to ask the sponsor
whether this is a correct understanding
um this would
happen annually I.E once a year and as a
further condition on that annual
process it could happen no later than 90
days before any
election so there are two conditions on
when it happens it must happen at least
once a year and no later than 90 days
before an election is is that the
correct way of understanding
the I thanks for the question I think so
I don't think
annually uh I would interpret that to
mean at least annually come out more
than
once was that the answer that you were
seeking representative your
head
no represent I don't understand
logically when something happens
annually there's no logical reason why
it couldn't happen more than once a year
um but the the bill doesn't ask for it
to happen before every election I wanted
to clarify that it's only requiring it
to happen once per
year could I respond to that
absolutely I don't know what you're
responding to but go for
it well I think in this in the second
line it refers to every type of election
does it
not believe that's line
four I don't have I don't have the lines
on my thing
sounds about
right all right further questions from
the committee representative Lane coming
in with the bailout thank
you thank you uh I think some of the
confusion is that the existing statute
says no less than
annually so I think part of that at
least for me because I read it the same
way representative mure had did that it
we were going from
that to one time per year and it had to
be 90 days before an
election I I I tell you what um let's
get deputy secretary Hennessy up here
let's finish our hearings on it and we
can actually work on it in executive
session today we won't noily vote on it
we can actually work on it um because I
think these questions probably would be
more um appropriate for executive
session yes representative Bo I just
it's been pointed out to to me too that
the last last sentence about all records
identified as moving should be revised
to be in English speak in English
excellent it isn't the records that are
moving it's the people fair enough um
any other questions for representative
Ward seeing none thank you um next up is
or my only other pink card I think let
me Jos verify that deputy secretary
Hennessy so representative gasowski if
you could grab the blue sheet for me
thank you Mr chair good morning again
everyone Aon Hennessy deputy secretary
of state I'm happy to answer questions
but first I would like to give our
offices
um uh desire for this legislation as you
all know we got a new Statewide voter
registration system last year when when
we do an
NCA um notification to Super ADV visors
it's not a um an easy process we have a
vendor that we contract with we have to
get all of the addresses names and
addresses in the entire Statewide voter
registration um system bumped up against
their list and it's not an inexpensive
process either our offices plans to do
this twice a year we think it's um um
very feasible financially to do it twice
a year but also um the the way the
language is written about the 90 days
before any election there are elections
that happen all year round um between
Municipal elections School Board
elections
um uh presidential primary State primary
general elections so that 90 days could
happen quite frequently and sometimes
those 90 days May overlap with each
other um so we're hoping to um just have
the language clarified a bit and that
you would consider consider two times a
year as a um possibility we also note
that there are many towns that still are
working on cleaning up their um NCA
notifications from when we've done when
we did the list in August so it is a
timec consuming as the sponsor noted a
time consuming effort for supervisors to
do this
um happy to take questions question on
the Comm represent
toner thank you is Is it feasible then
based on what you just said that if you
do a database refresh twice a year that
the towns can do their thing every
election but utilize whatever the most
up-to-date um data is from from the
Secretary of State thank you for the
question so just to clarify it's not a
data refresh it's um the each supervisor
is getting information that they need to
look at individually um Bas for voters
in their their towns and they need to
look at that each each voter at a time
did that voter actually move out of our
town and make decision based on what
they get so it's it's we're not updating
their database the supervisors um
control the database updates um based on
the information that they receive um and
twice a year I think is very feasible I
would say um in 25 our plan was going to
be to do it in June and November and 26
unless a date is changed for the um
primary it would be in April and
December
follow so it I'm trying to understand
the process
is who receives like the post office
basically um relocation or whatever like
um foring their mail basically
identifying that someone's possibly
moved who processes that compared to
um the voter registration so the
supervisors of the checklist or the
registers in um Portsmith this case will
receive in their electronic in the
Statewide voter registration system a
list of all the voters that have been
identified as people who have um
potentially and sometimes and that's why
they have to look at them individually
they may not be accurate matches um
potentially moved out of their town so
they they supervisors receive that
information because we've uploaded it
into the database for each um city or
town Ward and they have to make the
determination to figure out if they've
actually moved out of town um and if
they should be removed from the
database further questions from the
committee we got to come back to
representative weary we got to come back
uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you
deputy secretary for taking my question
um so the the once you do this uh
process two times a year is there a
notification sent out to the city Wards
and towns that this has been
done thank you yes anytime we've updated
the Statewide voter registration system
every time they log in the supervisors
will see they have this many um NCA um
voters to address there's a there's a
login screen and they've got a notice
you need to address these
things further questions representative
well I see if anybody else is first
repres m thank you didn't mean to
interrupt you representative wary I I
wanted to just clarify does the office
of the Secretary of State support this
legislation or endorse it and and I just
wanted to clarify
that I will say that we support this
legislation if it's to be done twice a
year um we just the 90 days before of an
election will have overlap of other
elections and so it would be very
difficult to get that information out
and done timely by the supervisor visors
especially those that have um a
different date of a town meeting and a
school board meeting um and use the same
checklist further questions
representative we what I we got to go
back to technically representative toner
repres toner do you want back in or you
all set all right now we go to
representative we uh thank you Mr chair
uh so
uh not to uh craft the amendment now but
uh
would you be okay with um you know
within 90 days of the secret Secretary
of State issuing a
ncoa update um that the supervisors of
the checklist would have to call their
list accordingly something like that
thanks for the question I would um I
would refer to I would ask that question
to the sponsor um as I said there are I
think that's two different things one
how many times we give them the
information and two when they have to
clean it up by
so representative Lane I thought this
was going to be an easy one two cards I
was
wrong hey um thanks for taking my
question and it's following up on
representative we's question when you
give the list when you give the list now
is there a time um because you mentioned
that some towns are still doing it but
it sounds like portsman jumped right on
it so so when you give them the list is
there a time frame that you are
expecting it to be done within thanks
for the
question um there's difference between
expectations and law and I don't believe
there's anything in law that requires
them to um address it in a certain time
frame further
questions all right seeing none thank
you deputy secretary representative Ward
you you indicated you may want him to
say something else he's going to wave
all right if that we'll wait till the
unnoticed EX where we won't vote all
right with that um I don't have any more
pink cards um so representative gusovsky
if you could please grab the blue sheet
have I already grabbed
it um online was 132 in support 16 oppos
and one neutral but the fluoride people
made a return
so they really don't want that
fluoride um so take it with what you
will going to close the public hearing
on House Bill
341 uh they are they want the removal of
the fluoride uh if you want I'll
actually happy to read the quote so you
don't think I'm just making it up uh the
repeated quote is fluoride lowers IQ it
is a toxic substance please stop
knowingly poisoning our families so I
don't know how um updating the ncoa list
is going to impact the fluoride and the
IQ but somebody clearly thinks that um
this is my filibustering to try to get
to 11 if you haven't gathered that's
what fluide can do apparently as you can
testify on the wrong bill um so I guess
we're going to stand the commit is going
to stand in recess for till 11:00 a.m.
which will be like in seconds so well I
I'm not going to jump into exec for you
know 10 seconds and it's 11 all right so
now we're out of recess um we don't go
by that cuz those are always wrong we go
by the uh I go by the the internet time
which exactly 11 so with that I'm going
to open up the public hearing for House
Bill
281 uh requiring electronic voter
checklist to be supplied in a sortable
format and I'm going to recognize
representative Wei for the purpose of
introduction thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee members for the
record my name is Bob war and I have the
privilege of representing Hillsboro
District 13 the great town of Hudson
this testimony will be exceedingly brief
so house buil 281 makes a few simple
changes to RSA
65715 the ability to obtain a list of
absentee voter applicants already exists
in the existing statutes and the RSA
allows for an electronic version to be
provided thereby cutting down the cost
on printting out copies of these lists
in in obtaining such lists however these
have often been provided to various
candidates in a PDF format while such a
format may be said to while while such a
format may be said to be electronic it
is not readily userfriendly or easily
sortable for the purposes of reviewing
such a list this simple Bill enables the
recipient of the list to be able to sort
through the list for reviewing purposes
I will be glad to try and answer any
questions the committee may
have impressive um questions from the
committee representative Lane hi thank
you for taking my question um down in on
line 15 and again on line 22 you have
added voter
address um right after you've asked for
the voter name and address where
registered is that not duplicative and
and and if it is and why is it
there the uh thank you for your question
um I I am you're you're absolutely right
I would uh I'd have to go back to the
original LSR and see if this was somehow
added by
um the OS but um it is it is already
there as you said so it's well it's
there in the first one but not the
second 22 22 is necessary 22 is Ah
that's that's perhaps the clarification
yeah 15 is not 15 15 is redundant 22 is
necessary because it confirms that the
list would be provided in accordance
with that what is up above in three
Roman numeral three so thank you for the
question because that helps clarify what
we need to do to amend I don't know I
think I violated the rules I totally
didn't ask a question I just made a
straightup statement um further
questions from the committee messing up
with my form I know I know um would you
uh I have one uh represent would you
would you believe that there um is
already debate amongst people about what
is a sort of format file type and we
should probably Define that so it's not
ambiguous while we're already beting
this bill would you believe that we need
to do that thank you Mr chair I I in
fact do believe that knowing that
sometimes uh those types of parameters
for providing lists can be difficult to
ascertain without explicitly Clear
Directions excellent all right any other
questions see that's how you do it the
wood you believes um all right um only
other one pink card is deputy secretary
Hennessy um so representative Kowski if
you could grab the blue sheet for
me thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Aaron Hennessy deputy
secretary of state I um want to let
everybody know that our Statewide voter
registration system is able to already
give give um a candidate information in
a sortable format I believe there's a
CSV and Excel option but I can get um
the chair that information for language
if you're going to amend the bill I
would ask that um well one last year the
committee made changes to um line 10 or
section three of the law and updated um
what information is available um if
that's your intention I would ask that
the um same language be updated to
section 3A of the
law which is also in the
bill qu will you be taking questions or
happy to take questions are there
questions seeing none thank you um there
was no one on the blue sheet uh on 20
online was 22 in support five opposed
and only two fluides this time and there
were two fluides again so I read the
comments I read the comments I don't I
read the comments you can't say I don't
uh with that we're going to close the
public hearing for House Bill 281 uh
we're going to go back into an executive
session stance I'm going to reopen the
noticed executive session for the house
election law committee um I'm going to
open the executive session for house
bill um 311 relative to permissible
campaign contributions by business and
or business organizations and labor
unions and I'm going to recognize
representative Harley bullia for a
motion yes thank you very much I make a
motion of itl on House Bill 311 FN
representative Harley bullia makes the
motion of inex speeding to legislate on
House Bill 311 is there a second
representative Burnham graciously
seconds I second it's okay I saw your I
saw your hand
move maybe um
is there discussion on the motion of any
speaking to legislate on House Bill
311 somebody say something while our
clerk did no she's got the sheet
representative
Lane I will accommodate representative
bam I'll just as I did on the other
campaign Finance laws these are designed
to be fair and um reasonable and to even
this one is to even the plane field
between uh again corporations and unions
the way they used to be before
1999 so thank you okay um and I will uh
I will rort to that uh I will agree to
consider this legislation when New
Hampshire moves to a stance of worker
Freedom until that point while we're
forcing unionization I'm not going to
level the playing field because it's not
currently level um are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 311 FN representative qua
yes representative P O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C yes representative gski
yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative G uh Gilmore
sorry no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative mil
willham no representative Nome no
chairman Barry chair votes yes without
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
carries on a vote of 10 to7
representative Harley buy will be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane who will have my
minority do we okay well we'll put you
down in the
temporary okay with that I'm going to
close the public the executive session
for House Bill 311
FN and going to
write down my notes Here go um and I'm
going
to actually um the only thing left is
houseb 175 we're waiting for the
amendment um any idea when that's
coming um all right uh 423 we're just
going to talk about which
[Music]
um 158 is a recess which we're going to
talk about it too um Okay so we've got
10 minutes um so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to open up the executive
session for houseb 423 this is the one
about uh signs on public property so
here's what I want to do um since we
have some time is I want to start um
we'll start from the right and I'd like
every member so if you could write the
law however you
wanted what is your i i b take 30
seconds to 60 seconds to give me and the
the the body what your vision would be
because I from talking with various
members it's all over the place and I
would just like to hear from everybody
in a formal setting of what it could be
and it can be the current law is fine
that that there's no wrong answer here I
just I genuinely want to hear so I can
get an idea because I would love to get
this issue settled so don't don't worry
about the language in the bill we're
talking about signs on public property
so representative kovski if you could
indulge us to start cuz I think I've
made my position clear
so um my view is I would like to have
the towns decide what they want to do
with the public property in town and
what about State Property
highways do you want to come back for
that yes okay we'll come back
representative
toner um I in my opinion there is an RSA
that Outlaws s finds advertisings from
political to companies on interstates
and and uh turnpikes and that includes
the
onramps um so I think that's covered and
if that it is the opinion of this
committee that law would need to be
changed and I I referenced it um when
this was originally being discussed as
far as like the right of
ways um if there's a situation where
right way or the state own own land in
front of your house I I think like 300
yard or something you know um if if that
is your property you should be able to
remove the sign um and and as far as the
right ways my understanding is if it's a
RightWay you still can basically either
put signs up if it's your property or
not that's that's my opinion so just
clarify so your kind of a butter
standard would be 300 yards effectively
I don't want to put words in your mouth
just trying to make sure I understand
yeah all right representative
c i was uh thinking that
maybe uh instead of the closest a butter
because the butter May own quite a bit
of uh Frontage would be just to limit it
to some particular distance maybe uh a
couple hundred yards from the front of
their house or business if that's what
it is um as long as it's open
land okay representative Bay
thank you for the question Mr chairman
um it's to me it's uh I I've I've not
really thought about it except for
during election when I see a lot of uh
signs and you know all all the highway
signs and all this like why why why they
do that because what what's the purpose
of that because if there are intention
of putting signs is to indicate that the
owner of the home where we have the sign
is uh is your supporter then you know
what what's what's indicator of uh if
you have your signs on the highway
having having said that um to me when if
there's a law and then there's a there
has to be a way of making sure that uh
everyone follows it and if there's no
way if like you make a law and there's
no way there's no uh for example if the
town makes uh those decisions and the
town does not have any funds to actually
make sure that it's followed then we
have a lot of really for nothing so I
think uh if uh there's going to be a law
there has to be how how it's going to be
implemented otherwise I will just stick
with what we have representative
Mirad I'm not sure I have a good
solution but I I I would I do think that
there I am convinced there's a need for
really clear standard um with respect to
federal state and Municipal property um
I might just note that the that the the
simple idea that the background
condition is that signs are not allowed
unless explicitly permitted by the state
or locality might be problematic for
many many residents who live on state
highways because the state right of way
extends pretty far into their front
yards and so they couldn't put their own
signs on that property adjacent to the
street in a visible manner um because
they technically don't own you know that
15 or 20ft swath of ground so so just to
throw out that complication but I do
think you know it's worth continuing to
hammer this out representative Freedom
O'Brien I always look at the signs that
are out and think about where they're
placed is it on someone's property or is
it uh elsewhere when it's on someone's
property I it means a lot more to me uh
but I may be looking at this it might be
inside baseball in a sense because I
look at it a little differently than
most people
just no signs on public property and I
know that's going to be difficult for
communities who have
Traditions but that's how that's where
I'm at representative Harley
bullia thank you Mr chair thank you for
the question um I I think at at a bare
minimum that we should definitely uh
allow a homeowner to remove the signs
that are placed directly in front of
their home and I know uh representative
wer was concerned about that he's on a
corner and so if the sign is you know in
front of the house it doesn't have to be
the facade of the house is fine and then
there was and you know the other bill is
talking you know there's several bills
that talk about uh Butters Butters is
not the correct term as far as I know I
looked it up and a Butters can be across
the street so you could have two people
so if you leave it to the abutter to
decide it should be a joining is the
language they're looking for joining
property a budding can be across the
street so you could have a conflict with
two different people um on who are both
equidistant uh but I I did go and I made
up these drafts a while ago which if you
want but it's um taking Senator Gray's
Bill about you know clarifying the ban
on uh state property signs and then
adding the bid about homeowners being
able to remove signs and then yes I
think public property you know no signs
but that's just me thanks representative
wood who has a position Stark opposition
of my own but let's hear it yes this I
don't think there's anybody here that
likes signs as much as I do uh first of
all the town our town already baned
signs however they don't enforce it and
we have what is called the First
Amendment rights so people who have just
a a point seem to uh get actually better
better locations than people running
because we're just um uh politicians our
Frontage if it's in front of somebody's
property take get rid of it everybody
understands the frontage in front of
their their house one of the few things
I have to describe when I was on the on
the zoning board or the the planning
board if it's in front of your house
remove it throw it in the trash so I
don't understand what happened before
but that's how it should go I don't
think we should change the law the
actually the state does a great job love
the dot we visit them uh twice a week no
about twice a month and uh they've taken
down signs pretty much they um give us
guidance they'll give you guidance it's
pretty hard almost all the land is
either state owned or Town Road when it
gets near the road uh I put signs up on
friend's houses that I believe they're
the only ones that see it because that's
the way property Works in uh Pittsfield
and and actually Chester we get a lot of
things off the beaten path so um when
this bill came out I looked around and
almost any place you would put a sign is
on state or Town Road the town doesn't
maintain what they have now we have
signs on polls we have signs for people
um sightings and all that stuff those
are illegal they don't even take care of
those signs which I'm not blaming
anybody I'm just saying those are
deposit of a nuisance the other thing is
that this it's pretty clear that after
the election you take them down and uh I
pretty much take down any political sign
after that uh period I just go out and
see my can uh my friend sirel uh is out
in the audience and we we go out and we
take down the signs both sides by the
way we take down both sign after that uh
I think it's a Friday uh two weeks after
so I think we handle this with the
current law representative
Ward thank you I would agree with
it uh the idea that cities and towns can
make up their own minds about these
things and seems to work out in a kind
of time onor traditional way in our town
state law is I don't have an opinion on
yet waiting to be
educated representative
quy thank you Mr
chairman I'm particularly interested Ed
in the idea of ensuring that
homeowners can remove signage
from Municipal rights of way or state
rights of way on property that adjoins
their property now I'm particularly
interested because I have a couple of
situations like that on my own property
I have several hundred feet where the
town I looked at my deed the town owns
the right of way for the street I live
on and the only way I can and where
exactly that
is is very difficult to determine on the
ground because it's a seamless patch of
ragged lawn that goes out to the edge of
the
asphalt uh I have a similar situation
because I also live on Route State Route
119 one portion of my property of
property lines defined as the US
geodetic Services uh like the 1,000 30t
elevation line try finding that on the
ground and another portion of my
property it extends to the uh New
Hampshire
Highway U boundary marker which I think
I found it's a a broken concrete
stump so if if I could legally remove
signs of that people who put up
adjoining my
property uh not in my case because I'm
not going to get in a conflict over
something like this but I think it would
reduce the potential for conflict around
the state between uh candidates and
property owners who whose property
adjoins where the sign is that's what I
would like to see put into effect and I
like I like the use of the word adjoin
because I think that's much clearer than
a butter in this instance yeah okay well
thank you it's 11:20 we're going to come
back to this so everybody over here gets
gets to Merit it on their opinion a
little longer um but it's 11:20 so we're
going to we're going to exit executive
session we're going to open up the
notice public hearing for House Bill 308
FN requiring the election checklist to
have a column to annotate if a non- New
Hampshire form of identification is
provided and I'm going to
recognize
someone do we have a pink card for 308
who's here for
308 no one this is going to be the
world's shortest hearing
uhoh see who else is on the
bill oh single spensor sponsor okay um
doesn't like the sponsors here um
representative toner can you can you get
up and just introduce House Bill 308 you
don't have to take any questions just
read the title so you're here to
introduce it and sit on back down
I'm representative Travis toner I
represent bellat for um Belmont New
Hampshire um I'd like to introduce Bill
uh House Bill 308 FN uh which is
requiring the election checklist to have
a column to annotate if a nonne
Hampshire issued form of identification
is provided to vote and I will not be
taking questions thank you um only only
pink card I have is from Sarah Burke
Cohen from the New Hampshire mpal
Association good morning still my name
is Sarah Burt Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association we
oppose HB 308 we feel that it is um
burdensome will be burdensome and
unnecessary it will be it will add more
confusion about types of ID as is
actually necess as is actually necessary
and it's adding more factors to report
to an already confusing process um for
those that are um running the checkless
um I'm open to questions are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um I don't have representative
dski if you could grab the uh blue sheet
for me online was 22 in support uh 220
oppos Zer neutral and yes fluoride made
a
reappearance um
grab this uh blue sheet which is it
represent is it blank representative
kazasi all right it's blank um so with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 308 and we're
going to reopen the executive session on
House Bill
423 um and um while the clerk gets are
you ready to give your opinion on signs
and public property would you like me to
go I can give my opinion okay
okay um um
so I think that it should be left to the
um the towns and cities uh I represent a
town with two Villages and a City ward
so they have the City ward has their own
rules where you can't um Place signs on
their on their public roads so it all
has to be done um by permission of U an
owner of a business or a home which
makes it really difficult when you're
not from that area either in my town uh
we have two
major roads which are state roads and we
have the Spalding um Turnpike that runs
right between us so those are the only
roads that we really have that are
available for the public to see unless
you're taking back roads to your home um
many people like to drive by my home
because there's always a lot of signs
but I think it makes it really
challenging for the individuals that are
running locally as well to have another
law that they may not be familiar with
and that they're breaking I uh and and
to be imposed on the local uh authority
to follow those procedures I just I
think it should be left to the towns and
municipalities where it's at I think the
state is doing a great job they allow us
to have signs along the road none are on
the um on ramps or off ramps um so so
and they usually allow two weeks for
everybody to remove their signs and then
they take them so that's where I stand I
think we should just leave it alone
thank you okay representative
Lane um I I'm not exactly sure how I
feel about this um and I think part of
that is because in my district it's it's
hard for me to put signs up because most
of them are apartment buildings or uh
manufactured home parks or condos that
have restrictions against signs so I
have a hard time finding a place to put
a sign uh in most of my um so including
my own condo where I live I can't put my
own sign up so um I guess towns and
cities I know conquered has some uh
guidelines and I I like uh others I'm
not quite sure about the state how they
want to do it I think you know the law
that representative toner mentioned is
adequate but I wor about those who are
um adjoining I think is the correct term
I think that's a great term um it and
but do you do it um and I like the idea
of a house but a lot of people's houses
are way set back so I'm not sure 300
yards would be sufficient but I don't
have a ready
answer representative
Wy since you created the Paradigm that
any ideal thought could go I would say
something like this is I'd keep all the
other existing laws I'd say right of way
shall not pertain to the placement of
election signs and the property owner
that is a homeowner or a business owner
shall have the ability to remove
election signs from their property and I
would just keep it at
that representative
Wilhelm uh thank you chairman uh
I I think we should make this enabling
for municipalities to do what they want
but otherwise there should be a ban on
putting political signs up around town
uh the state question sounds like it's
addressed in statute and probably
shouldn't be changed um but this has
been really helpful listening to what
everybody thinks it's why we had to do
it because there was just so many ideas
R
Nome thank you um I agree with uh many
of us I think I've heard today saying
that the town decision should be left to
the town SS to decide into by them um
the state I think current law covers um
what it needs
to uh as it pertains to a joining or a
budding or whatever that word is my
concern there is a first amendment
constitutional issue where it is
state-owned property and we're giving a
private citizen the right to control
speech on that state land where all of a
sudden it's it's no longer content
neutral uh um and that to me is a big
problem um as well as it's I'm I'm not
sure if people have heard the the
property rights as a bundle of sticks
analogy where each stick is a property
right whether it's mineral rights or the
right to build as opposed to a
conservation easement and giving an
abutter or a joiner the right just a
property right that's currently held by
the state just giving that away to me is
problematic
uh who's to say that that autter
couldn't then charge campaigns as to
what's who gets that sign um and that
potential for I'm not saying it's going
to happen but that potential for
monetization of controlled speech is a
real problem for me thank you okay and
representative
Gilmore well I think all political
signage should be on the property
personal property of its
supporters that's it
he's on team total ban um okay and I'll
I'll kind of reiterate my position um
so I I I like the idea of a total ban on
Town property um and County property
Byer County um total ban on Town and
County property um but the towns or
counties can adopt ordinances to allow
it in specific times and specific
locations um so if they want to do the
free-for-all on the corner they can
designate the corner corner for the
free-for-all if they want to do total
ban they can do total ban um and it's a
local control issue um so that's that
that's where I am on Town and County
when it comes to state-owned right of
way so you know I have a RightWay on my
property for a private the person that
lives behind me they have a right of way
driveway over over my land um so I think
I maybe I'm confused or someone or
that's not being conveyed properly about
um you still own that land even though a
highway you can you can own a land that
a highway runs over it's a state has a
right of way over your land you still
own the land um so I think that's where
I think I think we need to clarify what
we're talking about there if I own that
land I should be able even though even
if there's a state-owned right of way I
should be able to put my sign on that
land because I own that land provided
it's not blocking a sight line or
causing some sort of traffic Hazard but
I own that land the state happens to
have a highway over it but I own that
land um so that that's my world view on
that um outside of that specific
situation I would say total ban on state
land because now you're talking about
putting them up in state parks right
you're talking about um all sort of
things and I agree with repr of Nome on
the idea of it's coerced speech it's no
longer I love that term content neutral
it's no it's now coerced speech it's a
public forum that you have now invaded
um and you're you're putting your speech
out there and I think you know I have a
district now you know I had Manchester
and Lichfield at one point um but I've
had I've had farming communities I've
had urban communities now I have a town
with a village but it's also Rural and I
live in a very rural town so like I I've
seen I guess I've like seen it all um
and I don't think you know in in where
you've got Route 77 Route 149 Route 114
um those are the main drags through town
114 and 77 being the two main ones um
149 is just basically going to New
Boston but
um there's you know even on those
highways those are state owned highways
like there's businesses there's houses
like there's no I have no problem
putting my signs up on those
highways cuz there were homes and there
was all sorts of places to put them and
it was not a problem um and I've never
seen a situation like in Chichester like
my business is an epom I drive through
Chichester on Route 4 literally every
day literally every day there is that
place that sells buffalo meat there is
that there's multiple car dealerships
there's homes there's a lot respectively
repr with there's a lot of private land
through there half of my staff lives in
Pittsfield so I'm in Pittsfield all the
time there's a lot of I that's is that
28 that goes through Pittsfield
see familiar right um so I I would
respectfully disagree I think there are
opportunities for you I mean you guys
have that one spot where it makes a
diamond a triangle um on Route 28 but
it's the cut through from Route 4 people
cut through that little that little
Center um yeah and there's a lot of
signs in there right um yeah so but I I
guess my point like to kind of come back
full circle is I think the rules need to
be I think the rules from the state need
to be uniform I am wary about getting
into this world of a joiner and a butter
because then it's going to create
conflict um but I do sympathize with the
argument of you know if somebody puts a
sign it looks like it's your house but
if we ban it on State Property totally
then that's not really a problem anymore
now is it um right so I don't know
that's where I'm at um representative
Penza you're here we've we've already
done your bill but I will allow you to
introduce it if you'd like if there's
not an objection to reopening the public
hearing for it I don't have an objection
it's just um when we come back I have a
clarification on the easement piece for
you yes okay so I will I will come out
of executive session and we will reopen
the public hearing for 308 for a I guess
introduction got to press the button
there thank you Mr chair uh for the
record um representative Kelly Penza
straford District 19 I'm so sorry I um I
was looking we were in exec session and
I was looking at the clock and looking
at my schedule and and realizing I um I
wasn't here in time um um thank you for
opening it back up
so when I worked with OS on this um it's
because there are um there in straford
County there are some polling areas that
are not following I guess what protocol
is which is this column that if it is a
autate um New Hampshire for of
identification that they basically say
what form of identification it is and
then they list you know the state um
that's not happening I know that that's
probably in and maybe um secretary
scandin can speak about that I think it
it is in the election manual but when I
asked if it was actually in statute ol
searched for it and said it wasn't and
so that's why it's now in there so
basically you know my bill is you know
1819 and 20 and it's just um for it to
be there now I have heard when I
introduced this bill I heard from um
supervisors of the checklist in
different places around the state and
they said well that's that's it's
already there but the problem is is that
it's not consistently being used or
utilized so um I put it in statute for
that reason I know that that column is
there um but it's not necessarily being
used so for example um um we had a a
poll um a poll Challenger that was um
that spoke to uh four people as they
were checking people in um this was in
this was in Durham for example and they
were not familiar with having to do that
for any other identification that was
outside of um New Hampshire so some
people did it and some people didn't and
so that's that's the reason why it is
here right now um secretary skinin would
you speak to that could you speak to
that that's that's uh I don't know if we
can do that I don't know if you can do
that because it would be very important
to to kind of understand where it is in
the election manual not necessarily he
knows that off the top of his head so um
I was told it's not in Statue anywhere
that's why those those uh three lines
are put in and that's pretty much it and
I hopefully it becomes commonplace that
it's just one of the procedures that is
happening with um people that are
checking in
voters question will you be taking
questions sure are there questions from
the committee yes represent Newsome
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question would you be open to
an amendment changing supervisors to
include ballot clerks since they're the
ones doing the checking
in well it's just a um it just said
basically says the checklist shall have
a column four
supervisors so supervisors doesn't
necessarily mean supervisor of the
checklist it could mean ballot C but you
could change that wording if that would
be if that that's that's no problem for
me at
all okay further questions from the
committee see none thank you
representative Hennessy is that for this
[Music]
bill okay all right see what You' done
to US Representative po we have such you
know we we were nice we're having a nice
conversation now now we're back in the
hearings
all right uh rep and represent if you
could get a pink card for me too um and
deputy secretary Hennessy thank you for
this uh 308 part
two thank you Mr chair for allowing me
to speak members of the committee my
name is Aaron Hennessy deputy secretary
of state I was waiting to testify to
hear what the intent of the legislation
was from the sponsor so now that she did
um give intentions I just want to point
to the section of the law that um is not
addressed in the legislation there is a
different section of law that goes over
what happens on Election Day and
65913 is the section and in that section
it does say sorry I have to put my
cheaters
on
um the ballot clerk shall record the
state of issuance on the checklist in
accordance with uniform procedures
developed by the Secretary of State and
the color designated for such entries
um uh shall record the state of issuance
of the voter's driver's license or
identification card in the Statewide
voter registration centralized voter
registration data of Base within 30 days
of the election so the ballot clerks do
Mark what um state if it comes from an
out of state um the the ID is from
currently on on the checklist and have
to record that in SVS when they upload
the information um but I noted that in
the legislation it was asking for some
additional information like what kind of
identification was used um so if that is
the intent um much like another bill
that we discussed on Friday in the
subcommittee um there may be some
additional space that is needed on the
checklist and when a spa additional
space is needed if you've ever looked at
a checklist it already has a lot of
information on the line we may need to
put an additional line which could
double the size of the checklist so if
your town has 1300 Pages currently for a
checklist it could cause um 2600 page
checklists to be printed
out will you be taking questions I'm
happy to take questions okay are there
questions from the committee um I have a
question if no one else does do we
release a report on I'm going to switch
over to 659 since it's the same subject
um do we release the report of the
states with the out do we release an
aggregated report for which states we're
seeing the IDS from um my understanding
is no we've not released one and the
chair of the subcommittee has asked me
to look into that to see if he could get
a report so that's on my to-do list okay
any other questions from the
committee okay that's it all right so we
will reclose
308 uh and it's 11:40 so we don't get to
talk about signs anymore um I know
you're devastated I actually am de I for
what it's worth I actually enjoy that
conversation so I if you're bored by it
I'm sorry we're going to keep doing it
um think it's worth discussing more I'm
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill 130 FN relative to
arrangement of of a of candidates on
primary election ballots and I'm
recognize representative Flanigan for
the purpose of
introduction I'm sorry did I say exec I
in hearing my apologies we are in a
hearing we're going to hear
things thank you Mr chairman and members
for the record my name is Jack Flanigan
and I represent Hillsboro 45 which is a
float torial of four towns Hollis
brookln Mason and Greenville all On the
Border um I'm introducing the uh House
Bill 130 however uh secretary scandin
had sort of grabbed me uh when he knew
about this bill and he did know this
bill was coming because there's a little
history that I like to share with you uh
I ran in
2022 and I was primaried and with a
fourtown
floral and the way the system worked the
same person was first on the ballot in
all four
towns and I had went in front of the
ballot commission and said this was
wrong because most people when you get
that far down the ballot they just
checked the first name well they
reminded me that it was legal completely
legal and secretary scanon was there but
they reminded me that I was probably
going to win don't worry I can change
the law once I get in well I didn't win
and the person that beat me beat uh beat
the opponent by six
votes now I'm proud to say that I beat
the incumbent by 835 votes but it just
seemed like it was four years too late
but anyway um after introducing the
legislation uh or the bill excuse me the
uh secretary brought it to my attention
that he wanted to look at it and massage
it a little bit and who am I going to
deny the Secretary of State looking over
my bill and he made the changes and I do
have an amendment Mr chairman if I could
introduce that to the committee yep
that's permissible uh it's uh it's going
to be uh
d423 and I'll provide a copy to all the
members and if it's it's got a little
ink on it I AP okay let's just let's
have you discuss the amendment first cuz
um they're not going to be able to read
it and listen to at the same time
anyways so it's very it's very brief
okay uh yeah just go ahead and do the
testimony for it first in the interest
of time if you don't mind and then uh
we'll distribute it or the secretary can
hand it out yeah I don't repres I don't
like distribution of materials in in
hearings
so I understand
so in in producing the original bill I
tried to mirror the statute that deals
with the Senate primaries uh because
there was a from what I understand a
lawsuit years ago that forced the law to
be changed because there were uh members
or member towns rather that were uh
important in the primary for the Senate
um and at that point in time um Senator
scandin Senator I give you a demotion uh
secretary scandin um had said let me let
me look at it and he did and he made
changes and I wasn't going to deny him
um and basically it mirrors uh the uh
the statue as it pertains to the Senate
uh but it spells out a little bit
specifically on the you know the numbers
and the you know where it seeds the the
candidates and and that type of thing
and and I may defer to him because it's
more his language than mine but the
point was is I'm trying to make it so
that what I experienced in my
primary Mr chairman should I stop my
testimony or please continue all right
um so what I'm trying to do is make sure
it doesn't happen to somebody else
regardless of the party whether it's
Republican or Democrat is that um when
you get far down in the ballot you know
the position of the name is almost as
important as your background and I'll
leave the the the the the merits of the
the amendment possibly to secretary
scandin if that's okay do you want to
take questions I always am available for
questions other questions from the
committee see none thank you secretary
scan you're up next
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State uh and I just I want to comment
on the the rotation that is called for
in let's just start with House Bill 30
as it was
introduced right now in New
Hampshire every polling place every
every town that's a polling place and
every city Ward that is a polling place
doesn't matter whether they have
additional polling places in those uh
you know in a town or a ward every town
or city ward has its own unique
ballot and it is the same for every
voter that participates in the election
in that polling place so what
um house 130 as introduced does would
require a further rotation of candidates
names within that polling place which
means that we would have to print
multiple ballots with different name
configurations to be used within that
polling place which would create a
nightmare for everybody because um of
the counting process whether it's done
by a machine or whether counting teams
are counting the ballots because there
would be different name configurations
it would make it a very difficult
task so when I saw that uh on the bill
that representative Flanigan uh
introduced I suggested to
him uh a rotation scheme that would
work and Main and it would maintain the
individual single ballot used for a
polling
place what this calls for is that in a
multi- town state representative
district there would be a rotation
process where right now uh um we have to
rotate the order of names on the ballot
to make sure that that process is fair
uh that was ordered by a court some
years ago so we have a seating process
where a name is randomly chosen of a
candidate that will go first second
third all the way down this would allow
the first seed to be listed in the
largest town in the
district and if it's a multi-member
multi- toown
district number two seed would go in the
second largest town if there's a three
seed it would go in the third largest
town and then when you run out of
candidates and there are still more
towns that order would reverse to try
and balance out the population within
that District so this is a rotation
scheme that would work for state
representative the only caution I have
with this is that right now we have a
very complex ballot because we have
rotation schemes for every office on the
ballot it is different for state
representative and for state
representative we also have a further
staggering on the ballot so the names
don't line up on a horizontal line to
make it look like the horizontal lines
aren't running against each
other and this would require further
rotations and every time you add more
rotations it does create the opportunity
for mistakes on the ballot which is
something that we fear and dread and and
take every precaution um to make sure
that doesn't happen but um but it is a
concern so bottom line is the language
in this amendment I think would work for
further rotations for state
representative on a state primary ballot
uh but it does not come without the
complexities and the and the additional
proofing that will be required to make
that happen so with that I would be
happy to answer any
questions representative we uh thank
than Mr chair and thank you secretary
scanon for taking my question just on
line 12 should that be with uh followed
by the next to last seed it seem I'm I'm
I think that might be a error a is that
an error or am I reading that
incorrectly just tell me which line
you're on yeah so in 11 to 12 of the
amendment when it goes in continue in
sequence with the last seed followed by
the last
seed and continuing in reverse order
until the number of towns is exhausted I
should that say instead something like
the with the last seed followed by the
next to last seed and continuing in
reverse order until the number of towns
is exhausted I believe you're right yes
okay otherwise it reads like a Groucho
marks uh yes yeah good catch
so further questions represent
scene thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary for taking my question uh do
you know how many uh multi- toown
districts or multi- Ward districts there
are that would be affected by
this I don't I can try and figure that
out for you I don't have a number um you
know I will add that you know there
there are many singl Town multi-member
districts and this legislation obviously
would not impact
those representative
toner thank you is this going to C what
is your estimation on what is it going
to cause your office to do this
just a little more manpower you know the
proofing we spend a lot of time proofing
the ballots to make sure that they're
correct before they go to press and
occasionally we don't catch everything
and we have to do a reprint of a ballot
when you know a mistake is found but uh
this will add additional proofing time
that'll be required in the ballot
production
process further
questions seeing nothing thank you I
don't have any pink more pink
cards um so online we had see if the
floor people made a return they did um
seven in support 15 opposed one neutral
with that I'm going to close the public
hearing for House Bill 1:30 uh we'll go
to lunch early great day uh I'll see you
guys back at 1:00 stay in recess until
one uh there was nothing on the blue
sheet
talk to the talk to representative where
you
e
e e
okay it's uh past one o'clock so my
apologies but I ran
late um okay we're going to open the
public hearing for House Bill
714 me read the title uh creating a
single primary ballot and recognize
representative Mirad for the purpose of
introduction representative Mirad
welcome thank you I'm Russ Mirad I
represent Grafton District 12 which
includes Etna lime and Handover New
Hampshire
um and uh I was asked to introduce this
bill um at the request of several New
Hampshire ites who participated in the
the citizens assembly a three-day event
at St A's that was held last June
consisting of sort of equal numbers of
Republicans Democrats Independents bunch
of citizens got together talked about
politics discussed bro lots of breakout
groups and discussions and deliberation
about problems and solutions and and the
single ballot primary which is what this
bill would create was one of the
solutions that garnered 80% or more
support among the delegates to this New
Hampshire um citizens assembly I'll let
some of the participants to that say
more about that in a second the idea is
very simple that instead of having
ballots at primary on primary days where
you can only vote for Republicans or
only vote for
Democrats all the candidates would be on
one
ballot and every voter would have the
opportunity to vote for any candidate a
voter could vote for a Democratic
candidate for governor could vote for a
republican candidate um for the
executive counsel Republican candidate
or maybe even an Undeclared candidate
independent candidate um for the house
so they could pick the best candidates
regardless of what parties those
candidates identified with and the two
top vote getting candidates would go on
to the general election in a district
where there's one seat that's the idea
it's very simple some people call it a
blanket primary some people refer to it
as the Alaska model because it's used in
Alaska and some might call it a
non-partisan primary um and the
principle behind it is that when
taxpayers pay for elections and the
state administers elections then every
citizen should be able to vote for any
candidate who's in that
election right now the state's paying
for and administrating party selection a
party selection process for the parties
it's a huge subsidy to the parties and
voters have to compress themselves into
one of the parties in order to
participate on primary day as you well
know 40% of New Hampshire rights do not
identify with a party and for those
people they have to say at least for
that moment they're voting well I'm a
partisan in order to participate in the
primary um and there's of course a huge
disconnect not just in New Hampshire but
more so I'd say really in the country
between citizens and the people who
represent them in legislatures which is
why public opinion of legislates which
should be the most esteemed and most
powerful branches article one is the
legislature should be the most esteemed
and Powerful branches in in
constitutional democracy are the most
despised branches of part of
constitutional democracy today um and
and you look at New Hampshire 40% of the
state you know 40% of the citizens
refuse to identify a party um how many
independent Undeclared people are there
in our legislature in the house the New
Hampshire senate about 0% so the
disconnect is pretty
obvious this single ballot primary would
aim to strengthen the connection between
representatives and
citizens um some object that it's unfair
for people who don't strongly identify
with the party to select the party
nominees that go forward into the
general election and well if that were
true we wouldn't allow Undeclared voters
to participate in primaries and parties
have the option of having party caucuses
or party conventions they could select
their general election candidates the
way they select their state party chairs
but if they want to engage the common
sense of the broad citizenry through an
election that's run by the state then
they should allow every citizen to vote
for any candidate others object that
this would invite what's called
insincere voting or strategic voting
where say imagine you know I I as a
loyal Democrat um am in an election
where I can vote to select you know the
Republican nominee I might vote for what
I think is the weakest or most obnoxious
nominee thinking that they won't do very
well in the general election so it's I
vote for someone I don't like in order
to saddle my opposition party with a
weak candidate well this ballot the
single ballot primary would actually
eliminate strategic voting it would
eliminate it because every P you can
only do that when you're sure the
candidate you most prefer is going to go
forward into the general election like
when when on your side there's an
incumbent who's unchallenged or
something like that then you might I
don't know if you're really clever and
extremely cynical you know register with
the opposition party so you can cast an
insincere ballot it doesn't happen much
um it really it's only kind of the
political science geek club that does
this kind of strategic voting most
voters are are in fact sincere and vote
with Integrity but this this reform
would actually eliminate that by making
every primary contest a competitive
primary
you can never be certain that your
preferred candidate has is a shoe in and
it's going to go on to the general
election
so I think that by making primary
elections more compelling turnout will
increase and the common sense of the
citizenry will be brought to bear with
more effect on our elections and I think
that would be alog together salutary and
so that's why I I I viewed the request
from from from some constituents from
whom you'll hear and from delegates to
the Hampshire citizens assembly with
such sympathy thank you very much Mr
chair thank you will you be taking
questions yes are there questions from
the
committee seeing none thank
you um next up is margerie Porter with
New Hampshire
together good afternoon chairman Barry
and members of the committee um for the
record I'm margerie Porter I live in
Hill P Hillsboro and it wasn't too long
ago where I was sitting in your seats as
a
representative um trying to represent my
constituents and make decisions that I
hoped would make their lives better so I
appreciate how hard you work and I thank
you for listening to me for the past
year it's been my honor to work with New
Hampshire together a nonpartisan
nonprofit whose goal is to help
everybody everyday citizens become
civically
engaged our process help helps them to
identify common problems and encourages
them to work together to find common
ground and to seek workable Solutions
which then can be put into
action during the fall winter and spring
of
2324 we held listening sessions
throughout the state in every County to
hear our citizens concerns and to make
sure that we were hitting all the
demographics we um commissioned a poll
for from
UNH there were many issues that Rose to
the four of that poll and I know you
know some of them the cost of living
housing Child Care those were all there
but what surprised us was rising to the
very top was were three major themes
political polarization and how it was
dividing
us confidence in our elections and how
we needed to improve
that and the lack of Representatives
representation and respons
responsiveness of government to the
people that they
represent over a three-day weekend in
June New Hampshire together held its
first the first ever in the United
States Statewide citizens assembly at St
A's and representative Mirad mentioned
it I'll give you a little bit more
detail they came to address these issues
and to find a solution
we strove to ensure that the 50
delegates who participated were
demographically representative of the
state as a whole we worked hard to get
people from north and south east and
west we made sure that the uh CI the
delegates were of different political
Persuasions and as a matter of fact we
had a pretty good match of um and a few
outliers we had some green party folks
there we had Libertarians we had
Democrats we had Republicans we had left
leaning Undeclared we had right leaning
Undeclared and we had modate Undeclared
they were all there together in this
room these rooms at St
A's we made ground rules for respectful
dialogue and all had to agree those
rules delegates then chose a problem
area and they broke into groups and they
got down to work to do these four things
identify specific specific areas of
widespread concern in their chosen topic
here different perspectives and that was
one of the most important parts evaluate
promising Solutions we had um experts
there from all over um all different
aspects of their their issues that they
could listen to and tap into and if the
solution that they worked up required
legislation to take appropriate steps to
make it happen so in order for the
group's policy recommendation to become
an official recommendation of the first
ever citizens assembly it had to meet
the very high bar of
75% of those in attendance accepting it
and approving it and in fact the four
proposals that came forward exceeded
that they were all in the
80% this is a a nonpartisan group of
people Miss P your time has expired so I
need you to bring your remarks to a
conclusion please okay I just have one
more little par that's fine um I wish
you could have been there to see this it
was hopeg
giving and I one thing I want to leave
with you is that these were people your
constituents my former constituents who
saw a
problem and want didn't just want to
complain about it they wanted to find
solutions that
worked they are concerned about the
polarization and they feel they're not
being represented I urge you to listen
to them today because they will tell you
how people in the real world are feeling
thank you very much thank you will you
be taking questions yes I will are there
questions seeing none thank you next up
is Bill black on Deck will be Kate
Marquee Mr Black welcome to election law
thank you very much thank you for
inviting me here to testify in support
of HB
714 um I am a retired physician and
researcher from Hanover New Hampshire
and I also work in the as a volunteer in
the
elections
um went blank
uh uh I was also a volunteer uh delegate
to the citizen assembly that you just
heard about this past June I was one of
50 uh volunteer delegates to that um as
Dr or Mr mad said before the uh single
ballot primary with a single ballot
primary the separate Democratic and
Republican ballots would be replaced by
a single nonpartisan ballot for all
Statewide and Congressional um uh
primary
elections the single ballot would
include all the candidates from all the
parties and each candidate would have
the option of including their a partisan
affiliation by their
name the single ballot primary would
provide benefits to the voters to the
candidates to the elected
representatives and to the general
public for Undeclared voters the single
ballot primary would allow them to or
would eliminate the need for them to
declare a major party before voting for
all all voters it would allow them to
vote for any any of the candidates from
any of the
parties for the um non- major party
candidates it would make their filing
requirements more fair for the major
party candidates it
would it would give them it would help
them compete against the more partisan
members of their own party
for and the single ballot primary would
have the effect of encouraging all the
candidates to appeal more broadly to the
constituency and to use less
inflammatory rhetoric and uh fewer uh
false claims Mr Black your time has
expired I'm me ask you to bring your um
remarks to conclusion so everybody knows
we operate on a two-minute public
testimony clock and election law okay um
so I I'll just finish with the fact that
uh even for elected uh
Representatives what it would do it
would um it would allow them to vote
their conscience and to uh represent
their constituency without the fear of
being primaried from an smaller uh more
partisan special interest group or an
out ofate special interest group and for
the public this is my last sentence for
the public it would uh reduce partisan
uh polarization and it would improve
political
representation and the responsiveness of
their
government okay will you be taking
questions from the committee yes are
there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um
secretary scanland would you like to go
now um or do you want to wait till the
end okay that's fine uh next up is Kate
Marquee after that is Tiani Coleman
hello um my name is Kate Marquee I live
and own a business in Manchester serve
on our Housing Commission and and am a
member of our resoning steering
committee I have also been an election
worker and served as a selectman which
in Manchester is basically an elected
election worker um so I'm here to
support House Bill 714 to create a
single primary ballot as an election
worker through several election Cycles
it has been my experience that primaries
caused frustration among part parts of
our electorate I cannot count how many
times I've heard I just want to vote for
this person and I don't care what party
they're a member of with the number of
Undeclared voters in our state easily
outnumbering the number of registered
Democrats or of registered Republicans
this is an opportunity for New Hampshire
to lead in ensuring the people's vote
directly chooses our candidates
regardless of party I also participated
in the New Hampshire together citizens
assembly and was a member of the group
tasked with exploring policy that would
reduce electoral
polarization we were a very group very
diverse group of individuals politically
far uh from far left to far right
everything in between and outside of
that spectrum and we were all residents
of the state who cared very deeply about
the work we were doing through
discussion we discovered that we all
felt having a single ballot primary
would reduce polarization by allowing
the majority rather than a minority pick
candidates for the general election it
was really one of the few Concepts we
all agreed on that we felt would
actually reduce
polarization Manchester and NASA both
hold successful single ballot Municipal
primaries nonpartisan I have worked the
Manchester primary there are less
questions and conflicts with the single
ballot and no concerns from Undeclared
voters about being left out of the
process there are four states in the US
already doing this and they report it
has not favored one party over another
this is an impactful tangible way to
hear all of New Hampshire's registered
voters in the primary process I ask that
you please support HB 714 which gives
voice to all New Hampshire's registered
voters thank you okay will you be taking
questions I will if people have them are
there questions from the committee
representative
Gilmore besides Alaska what are the
other three
states oh that is a great question
Nebraska Louisiana Washington California
it's two blue and two red States yeah
representative Lane do you have a
question
w nine right yes yeah Ross that's right
see look at
that great memory um next up is uh
repere she gets to cut sorry I we let
the rep because we're in SE we're in
committees so I usually let the
representatives cut I apologize that's
treat them all
fairly apologies thank you Mr chair and
thank you honorable members um for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 which's new market and new
Fields I am in support of the concept of
the bill I am a supporter of open
primaries however I believe as written
and I know that this was worked on by a
number of people um as written this
could cause more harm than good if the
committee is serious about the concept
of an Open Primary um you're not going
to like what I have to or some of you
won't like what I have to say so the
problem is the problem that I see
is that um what we call single party
sweeps so for example we are familiar
with uh multi-member districts as state
reps and you may have a district that
is
60% party orange and 40% party
purple and you have multiple seats and
this is a multi-member district because
you have a top two so it's like having a
two- member district right even though
numerically you might expect a lot of
times that to be split one orange
representative one purple you often get
that 60% determining all the winners so
you may for this purpose end up with
only one party represented on the
general ballot depending even if the
even if the votes were only like 55% in
favor of one uh party that's 45% of
people whose voice isn't being heard for
the purposes of candidates on the
general ballot
and I'm sorry if I was drawing an
analogy that got confusing I was
relating the concept of a primary to the
general ballot the way we relate a
multi-member district because what you
have is when you have top two or top
three or top five you essentially are
creating a multi-member
district the other thing is that we
already suffer from a decreased turnout
in primaries and what this does is um
amplify that problem there is a way to
get around that problem and around the
problem of having the single party
sweeps and that's is to make the results
proportional to the votes and this is
where I might get push back there is a
easy way to get make that proportional
and it's called rank Choice voting I
promise I am not simply testifying to to
talk about rank Choice voting but an
Open Primary without rank Choice voting
has the potential of uh amplifying the
very small voice of people who who turn
out to a primary not just the people who
turn out to a primary but a narrow
majority of people who turn out to the
primary are dictating all the people on
the general ballot but if you do with
with rank Choice voting there's two ways
to do it you end up with proportional
representation on that General ballot so
now you have the 45% or the 35% um
getting some uh selection that appeals
to them on the general ballot so you can
either do single transferable vote which
is what rank Choice voting is when it's
applied to a multi-member district so if
you had like a top four or top five um
you could do single transferable Vote or
you can simply set a threshold say
15% um and any candidate who gets over
15% would end up in the ballot so that
wouldn't be a top two or top three that
would just be whoever gets over 15%
which would be between two and like six
candidates on the general ballot
represent I'm going to ask you to bring
your remarks to a conclusion we've gone
over all right I'm with that I'm happy
to take questions I just I see issues
with how it's being proposed to be
enacted um I don't like the idea of of
having only one party on the general
ballot which would become a problem um
and but there is a solution and I do
support the concept of open
primaries questions from the committee
seeing Oh representative Grill you've
joined us to see you is your car fixed
excellent next up is uh Tiani Coleman
and then Warner horn is on Deck
hello I'm Tiani Coleman and I'm here
today in my capacity as myself an
independent voter as well as a leader of
a non-partisan citizen group called New
Hampshire independent voters I do other
things I'm not here in that capacity
today um so I have been a resident of
New Hampshire for over 11 years
and as an independent voter that entire
time I became an independent voter
unaffiliated voter about 12 years ago
but about 20 years ago uh I was the
chair of the largest county in the
Republican party chair of the largest
county in Utah over a million residents
and I worked in the inner Circles of
Party politics within that County and
within the state and then later I became
a campaign caign manager for a US
Congressional candidate who was a
moderate Democrat running in one of the
most conservative counties counties in
the state so in th those two experiences
I was able to um experience inner Party
politics in areas where you didn't have
very much power as well as like in the
capital city of Salt Lake City proper um
Democrats actually had a lot of power
but in the state Democrats had no power
so I I got to watch a lot of things and
I I came to see that corruption does not
belong to any party corruption belongs
to power and that was when I started
thinking what can we do to change the
way the electoral system works in the
state which was a caucus system and
there was a lot of things I'm not going
to go into it but I started thinking we
really need to make some changes and I
I'm also an attorney and I came across
Justice
scalia's a little after 2010 I came
across Justice scalia's Artic landmark
decision in um
California excuse me Democratic party V
Jones that came out of California where
they decided that a uh that
a what was it called a ballot a what's
it's called a um blanket primary they
decided that a blanket primary was
unconstitutional a blanket primary is
when you do it single ballot but you're
still choosing the party nominees but
Justice Scalia had a little sentence in
there that really piqu my interest and
it was a sentence that said but parties
don't have elections primary elections
don't have to be by party nominees you
don't have to be selecting party
nominees in a primary election they can
just do a nonpartisan he could call it a
nonpartisan if it's nonpartisan and
you're not selecting the primary
nominees then it's perfectly
constitutional and I was like wait what
and that's when I started you know
really working hard as an electoral
reform former working in favor of such
things such as nonpartisan primaries
so I I favor nonpartisan uh single
ballot primaries because independent
voters rights are very important and a
law review article in
2019 I can you to bring your remarks to
a conclusion your time is way way past
I'm trying to get your attention oh
that's really too bad because I have so
much more to say but uh let me just say
let all voters vote uh Independence and
the expansion of expansion of voting
rights in the United States is a very
important law review article Taro law
review where they talk about how U the
rights of independent unaffiliated
voters is one of the New Frontiers of
the Civil Rights and the Voting Rights
struggle and as an independent voter and
as independent and people who are
independent candidates really need to
have a Level Playing Field in the in
electoral politics to be able to not to
be able to open up the market of the
political system right now we have a
closed market and the state is funding
two
people two parties and then they're
saying that they're only going to choose
one person out that party I'm going to
have to ask you to end because I if I
don't if I don't enforce it on you I
can't enforce on anyone so I'm going to
have to ask you I I believe I I've given
deference iow can I have one more
sentence I'm sorry I'm not going to
allow that I've already allowed you to
bring your marshing inclusion please
allow me because it's really please just
one more sentence I'm I'm going to
respectfully decline because I need to
enforce the rules uniformally and I'm
sorry um next up is Warner horn she take
questions she can't take questions she
questions yes that's
fine you like questions yes I do have a
question you referenced a 2019 article
um could you make sure that it gets into
the committee's um hands so we can
review it yes I can send you a link to
that article so that you can read it the
article itself is not about nonpartisan
primaries per se it's about the rights
of independent voters it's about the
importance of of voting rights of
independent voters further questions
from the
willlam thank you chairman thanks for
taking my question what was the last
sentence you were going to say as part
of your
testimony I'm going to roll that out of
order as much as I do love the tongue
and cheek of it U thank you uh next up
is Warner
horn welcome to election
law thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Warner horn and uh I'm going to help the
committee by not repeating all of the
excellent points you guys have heard
already instead uh I'm going to give you
my feedback on the citizens assembly
that took place in June Through The Eyes
of a former
legislature so I went to the committee I
was intrigued by their offer of civil
discourse about all sides being hurt
equally and to my great surprise
they meant it we had 48 hours over 3
days of excellent communication
respectful discourse points were heard
and when there was disagreement there
was no polarization of feelings
everybody walked out of there at least
willing to shake hands if not willing to
stay civil and the most intriguing thing
to me as a former legislator
was they were bringing information
forward that I would not have considered
in any other like context I've had more
than enough constituent engagement as a
representative and they were saying
things to me that I hadn't
heard which makes me think there is
exceptional value to the organization
and the process by which we got this
legislation out we as legislators are
starved for the information that helps
us make decisions we go to Great Lengths
to secure it for these individuals to
have organized and produced a way for us
to learn more about what the New
Hampshire citizens are thinking and
feeling that's exceptional and valuable
and with that Mr chairman I'm happy to
take questions okay are there questions
from the
committee representative Lane uh thank
you for taking questions um and um both
representative will ham and I were at
the conference and I Echo you correctly
explained what happened so thank you um
my question is what other things came
out of that of this assembly than this
bill and do they relate to this bill or
do you
know uh
so I'm sorry could you repeat the
question were there other initiatives
that might be related to this bill that
came out of the
assembly there were three initiatives
that passed this 75% threshold and they
were all fairly unique um in that
respect so any of the other things that
were discussed wouldn't have made the
75% um margin and wouldn't have been
valuable connected to this specific
legislation further questions from the
committee saying none thank you uh next
up is Eric here and then on Deck is
stepen Bourne
thank you Mr chairman I speak this
afternoon in support of HB
714 I am Eric her resident of Hill New
Hampshire the bookends of my career have
been Public Service First on the staff
of a republican president's Council of
economic advisers and in New Hampshire
assignments for every Governor from
Shaheen through
sununu elections took on a special
significance for me when as Hill
moderator I watched our citizens
exercise their right and duty to vote
but it was striking that voters First
Act at the polls was to choose a party's
primary ballot despite independent
voters being the state's largest voting
block perhaps we should revise our motto
Live Free or Die but vote Republican or
Democrat today the purpose of our
primary partisan primary system is to
nominate a Republican and a Democratic
candidate for public office effectively
making voting districts agents of our
two political parties and local
taxpayers the funders of that
agency but the essential purpose primary
should perform is to ensure that
candidates making the general election
ballot reflect the will of the citizens
of New Hampshire independent of party
affiliation three essential
pro-democracy principles follow first
that all votes
count second that all votes cast for a
candidate are tallied in that
candidate's total vote count and and
third that all candidates are treated
identically our primary process partisan
primary process fails these principles
to illustrate today a right-in vote on a
Democratic primary ballot for a
candidate on the Republican primary
ballot is not included in the total vote
count for that Republican
candidate effectively the vote doesn't
count and that Republican candidate's
total vote account does not reflect the
will of all the
people HB 714 remedies these
anti-democratic
failures at Gettysburg Lincoln
memorialized our national sacrifice to
preserve a government of the People by
the people and for the people with your
support of HB
714 you have the opportunity to place
the people not political parties at the
center of New Hampshire's primary
elections your vote will speak volumes
thank you Mr chairman thank you um Mr
here will you be taking um phone phone
calls we be taking
questions wow my mind my mind just
slipped slipped a gear there real fast
are questions from the committee seeing
done thank you um next up is Steven
Bourne and on Deck is Daryl
D'Angelo is that written
testimony uh just put it on that side of
the desk for me
oh you're going to reference it then it
can be distributed that's fine my
apologies yeah so so those so no if you
have copies of written testimony we put
them up front for collection later if
you have something you're going to
reference in your testimony like a graph
or something like that obviously we have
to have that to hear
you but that stops the
uh what I just did the paper well
what'll happen is towards the end of the
day it'll just be like and it can't find
anything all right we're ready to go
when you are all right thank you I'm
step Bourne from Ry um if you know me
you know I'm not political or
ideological I'm an engineer and I can't
stand something that's not working I've
been at this for over 20 years I passed
out examples of some of the things I've
been doing inition of being on the
planning board budget I wrote a book um
those numbers I'm going to ask you to
help me demonstrate right now so I would
like you to all briefly to stand up and
Russ I used 18 so can you stand up too
just briefly stand up pleas the committe
got to remain seated I'm sorry the
committe it's very hard to demonstrate I
I understand but you're going to have to
we to use our imaginations I don't care
what the public does but the I'm going
to ask the committee members to stay
seated all right so much for the effect
um if everyone um stood all right I was
the points I was going to make that you
represent the 1.1 million registered
voters for about 96% of the people whove
registered to vote all right our common
goal should be have 100% of the people
particip ipating in all local and state
elections all right with the one goal of
managing our government better in
November 2024 we only had 75.5% of the
people registered voters vote so it's
going to have four of you sit down Russ
and two of the others okay now get a
picture of that besides looking at it
all right um now in September all right
only 222% of the people who voted
participate in the SE primary so we're
going to round up to four all right and
that leaves everyone else that represent
the 78% of the people who voted in
November all right but did not
participate in the primary all right so
everyone sitting who is going to be just
about everyone else except for the
people at the ends all right you need to
hope that the people sitting or the
people still standing those four people
all right represent who you want to see
on the November ballot all right what
you're looking at with just four people
representing all of you is a leverage
system all right a disproportional
amount of people have power greater than
their size all right that's dis known as
disproportional power all right um our
pedison Pro process because of that's
broken all right there's also other
issues this caused in 2022 I ran as an
independent when I asked people who had
already voted if they voted for me none
did they also admitted that they had no
idea of who the Republican or Democrat
options were as we just had a great
conversation and they were not enamored
with the other party I asked why not
support an independent everyone said
they voted against the party that scares
them the most in our New Hampshire
system people are voting against not for
people for many Undeclared voters like
myself there are people running in the
primary on both sides that I prefer much
more than those who make it to the
November ballot we're paying for the
primary and I want the right and the
freedom to vote for the candidates I
like regardless of party affiliation the
parties are not paying for these
partisan primaries we are after the 22
September primaries I did some back ofth
math envelope to estimate what cities
and towns pay all right it worked out to
be around 4.5 million what cities and
towns pays that does not count what the
secretary of state pays for these that's
something that
900,000 people in New Hampshire did not
not use all right it's no mystery that
the New Hampshire citizens assembly this
came out as something we should move
forward so the first thing I did well
I'm at the your your time's expired so
if you can well I had to use a lot of it
not getting you to stand I I understand
but your time has expired so just
briefly I went through all the rsas went
through and what I learned all right is
that um the we've create the our rsis
rsas have created two classes of people
those in the parties and those who are
not all right it keeps people from
participating in the process all right
and everything you're going to hear all
right opposing this all right is a
challenge none of this is a showstopper
everyone is a solvable problem myself
and others are more than willing to work
with us to make this change that should
get us our common denom goal which is
getting more people participating in our
process I will be more than glad to
answer questions for two 10 minutes or
30 minutes there is no time limit on
questions I've never imposed one of
those so all right so I handed out a lot
of stuff and ask anything you ever
wanted to know about are there questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you all
right lucky I'm in sales and I'm not
hurt uh next up is Daryl D'Angelo and on
Deck is Lynn
Briggs hi I'm nervous sorry
my name is Daryl D'Angelo I'm from
Amherst New Hampshire I have been an
independent unaffiliated voter my entire
life um and I've drifted in and out
through the primary process here but
always immediately disaffiliated because
I kind of float that way um and over all
these years I've watched things move
further and further away from
representing me we often speak of the
state as a controlling and limiting
entity but at its best government seeks
to remove barriers that prevent people
from freely exercising their rights and
freedoms HB 714 is an effort to increase
freedom and choice for all Granite
Staters our current system is
experiencing multiple
problems for one toxic polarization is
NE negatively affecting our state it's a
phenomenon it didn't originate here we
didn't start it but it's hitting us very
very hard and it's creating an
environment of fear I was a ballot clerk
for many years our Town won't let me
participate anymore as an unaffiliated
voter because they're worried about
challenges I need they only want an even
number of registered people at the
tables now uh anger and marginalization
are leaving to disenfranchisement
withdraw from the process the people
that do participate misuse the process
frequently just to cast no votes we're
stifling the marketplace of ideas we are
blessed by the foresight of our Founders
who codified freedom of speech in our
first amendment
it's often said that the best answer to
bad speech is more speech nowhere is
this more true than in the marketplace
of ideas yet our current primaries
systemat systematically exclude the
voices of everyone not directly
affiliated with one of only two
political parties and competition is
being stifled with competition requires
free speech and equal ability to discuss
and debate ideas and finally we have
unequal ballot access as publicly funded
events our primary elections must by
definition be open to the public but
that doesn't merely mean voters public
includes the voices of the largest
voting Block in our state the
unaffiliated our primaries provide
Public Funding for private organizations
the parties and since the public foots
the bill the barriers to participation
have to come down HB 714 recognizes and
attempts to remove these barriers our
forefathers fought for their
independence from England because as a
colony they were being taxed but had no
representation representation is
fundamental to America's liberal values
as a New Hampshire property owner I help
fund our state primaries but as an
independent unaffiliated voter I'm not
represented in the process independent
voters have no primary candidates from
which they can choose other than those
of the two major parties I hope the
committee moves this bill forward thank
you thank you will you be taking
questions are there questions seeing
none thank you um next up is Lyn Briggs
and on Deck is Linda
Bundy good
afternoon Bill 7114 oh sorry ly Briggs
amers New Hampshire Bill
7114 to me speaking as a ballot Clerk of
several years I am no longer a ballot
Clerk
is a problem because I would watch
Undeclared which is not a party come in
and be very aggressive very angry for
whatever reason I'm not making judgment
and demand a ballot or not when they
were finished uh voting they would go
get into the line where you change
back it seems to me that
that is a
really disgusting way to behave
a horrible way to have to choose so if
we have a Republican party and a
Democrat Party which are private
entities then maybe we need an
independent Undeclared is what it is an
inde an independent party that is
privately funded just throwing it out
there from my my observations and what's
been going on last week I did um
testify about the
Undeclared not choosing a
party by the first Wednesday in June
it was extended to
October that allowed 4,000 plus
Democrats to become independent or
Undeclared which again is not a party so
we either have to choose the two parties
the private
parties in in June to participate in the
primary or we need to go to three
private parties and I'll just keep it
that
simple okay uh questions from the
committee
um I will say I am glad actually you
reconciled that cuz I was wondering how
you were going to get there and you did
so cool um so thanks for that I I sitt I
was like you were just here last week
and you didn't say that you didn't say
uh next uh any other questions from the
committee uh Linda Bundy and then on
Deck is uh Kaylee
estadio yeah
I'm it's going to get to the point where
I don't even look for validation on it
anymore I'm just going to know that I
got it right
good afternoon chairman Barry and
members of house election law my name is
Linda Bundy and I'm from
antrum in June 2024 the New Hampshire
together citizens assembly brought
together 50 New Hampshire residents
representing a cross-section of the
state's demographics and political
ideologies over three days of discussion
and debate they found common ground and
de decided upon four key recommendations
S one of these was establishing a single
ballot primary a single ballot primary
allows all voter to consider all
candidates without being restricted to
one
party the largest group of Voters in New
Hampshire is Undeclared not Republican
or Democratic there is a stronga
tradition of people voting across party
lines it makes sense to simplify voting
in the state and Congressional primaries
this system would give voters more
choice and ensure that Winners have
broad support our current system leads
to both parties nominating candidates
with more extreme views both left and
right a single ballot primary is a step
toward reducing polarization because it
does not favor any side I've worked as a
ballot clerk in Anum since
2022 and there always are Undeclared
voters who do not like having to declare
a party in order to vote on a number of
occasions when I've explained this to
them they have stated I want to vote for
the candidate not the party a single
ballot primary eliminates the time and
busy work that Undeclared voters and
election workers have to spend choosing
a party before voting and then switching
back to Undeclared after I agree with a
diverse group of New Hampshire citizens
from the citizens assembly who believe
that a single ballot primary system will
best serve our voters by reducing
polarization and providing more
meaningful choices thank you for the
opportunity thank you so much Miss Bundy
I assume you're not taking questions by
you're getting up that's totally fine
next up is Kaylee estadio and uh then on
Deck is our own David
scanland well we do elect him so he is
our own
think about that I just blew your mind
there didn't I good afternoon um thank
you chairman Barry and members of the
committee for the record my name is Kaye
abrao I'm a Durham voter and public
policy fellow with open democracy we're
nonpartisan nonprofit representing
36,000 voters across the state and today
I am testifying in support of HB
714 um as the merits of the bill have
already been highlighted I want to focus
on today's party
polarization um the
constructed Union was quote its tendency
to break and control the violence of
faction which I think we could all use
today and with HB H with HB 714 this
committee has the opportunity to do just
that the primary voting system should be
built around the needs of the people it
serves and not the other way around this
is not the case today as New Hampshire
taxpayers essentially subsidize
political party Party candidate
selection for the two major parties
despite Independence making up the
majority of the voter voting block a
single party ballot would work to bring
the power back to the people and away
from the party systems two blue States
Washington and California and two red
States Nebraska and Alaska currently
utilize single ballot party single party
ballots in their primaries and none have
found that the system favors one party
over another so for these reasons I urge
you to vote a to pass on HB 714 to put
people over party and better meet the
needs of all graters thank you and I
will take questions if there are
okay are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you last up
is Secretary of skate skate Secretary of
State David scanland and representative
gazi if you could grab the blue sheet
for
me a chance to take it all in Mr
secretary now you get to
oine thank you Mr chairman I'll I'll
keep this brief um first of all I did
have the opportunity to address the
citizens assembly uh when they met last
year it it was a really good exercise
and I hope that kind of dialogue
continues around the state um they did a
lot of outside the box thinking and I
think that house bill 714 reflects that
but it would represent a really
fundamental change in the way that we
conduct elections in the state and it
would be heading in the direction of
nonpartisan elections very similar to
what we do at Town elections now where
you know people from whatever political
iCal persuasion get on the ballot and
the voters select the one that they want
to serve as Selectmen or planning board
member uh
whatever this bill does have
consequences from the standpoint of an
election
administrator having a single ballot
does not mean that there's going to be
less paper because you're still going to
have the same number of candidates maybe
even more if Undeclared voters are
allowed to participate uh on that ballot
and so it would either be a very very
long Ballot or multiple pages so I don't
think that there would be a lot of
savings uh in that
department and then there could also be
unintended consequences representative
Reed uh did a good job explaining how
uh a community that is heavily uh
belonging to one party could dominate
the ballot and the other the reverse of
that could be true if you had a number
of uh of candidates from one party and
just one or two of the other party where
the many candidate uh gets deluded and
and the two minority candidates might uh
survive the
primary and then what happens after the
election's over and comes time to
prepare the general election ballot when
you have let's say two members of One
party that won the primary and no
members of the other party and you still
have party columns um how does that how
does that ballot configuration look um
you know I think that would require some
statutory changes to sort that
out so I think uh those would be the
concerns that I have Mr chair I'd be
happy to answer any questions if there
are any okay are there questions from
the committee
representative
Gilmore Dave have you ever looked at any
of the California Alaska Nebraska
Washington Singo I just if you have just
cares I've looked at California
California on a regular basis goes
through a primary and ends up with
candidates on the general election that
are just from that one party that won
okay and you know if you're if you are
let's say that happens you have two
Democrats that win and they're running
against each other in the en
election the Republicans in that
District are kind of disenfranchised
because they wouldn't have uh somebody
on the ballot that
represents you know their
viewpoints uh in a general election uh
thank you further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you this qu
from you Mr wilh or did you receive a
text
message I I've got a question oh okay
okay well we'll allow it I miss should
to hear Mr secretary do you could you
just talk about the administration of a
primary like this like what what
challenges do you see would it is it
something that you could do or what what
are some of the changes to statutes that
you think would need to be made in order
to execute something like this it would
require quite a bit of thought
um we would have many more candidates
running in the primary when you're in
erating all the candidates from both
parties and maybe maybe other parties uh
were Undeclared that want to run uh we
would have to come up with a fair
rotation scheme uh which we had talked
about earlier today and then try and
figure out how that would work along
with their party affiliations would they
be listed on the ballot um how would
that
work
um yeah I mean they would be primarily
ballot layout
issues okay all right further questions
from the
committee seeing none um thank you
representative SC I don't think I have
any more one else signed up to speak on
this um so we're going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 714 I know
we are running a little behind but we
are going to exec 175 right now because
we have some members that need to depart
um so I'm going to open the notice
executive session uh for House Bill 17 5
and I'm going to recognize
representative Mirad for a motion on
House Bill
175 thank you I would like to move to
OTP 175 represent makes a motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 175 is there
a second representative Lane seconds are
there any
amendments representative William is
recognized thank you Mr chair I'd like
to introduce and move Amendment uh 0416
H represent Wilhelm moves Amendment
2025-the
uh just to speak to the amendment
briefly this uh amendment is pretty
simple it would just move the effective
date to January 1st 2027 so that it
doesn't impact the current uh election
cycle for 2026 Is there further
discussion on the
amendment hearing
none uh we can do this by a Voice vote
so are you ready for the question all
those in favor of adopting Amendment
20254 61h say I I all opposed say no the
eyes have it is there a new
motion representative Mirad move otpa
representative Mirad moves OTP moves
House Bill 175 Beach to passes Amendment
with Amendment 25-0 4618 representative
wilham seconds him we're now on
discussion of the motion of ought to
pass as
amended hearing none the clerk will call
the
role representative qua no
representative Poma bran no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Harvey bu
no representative C no Representative
gski no representative toner no
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes rep representative Grill yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Newsome yes chairman
Barry chair votes no with that the
motion of ought to pass as Amendment
fails on a vote of 10 to eight um
representative toner is recognized for a
motion I'd like to motion that house
bill
175 um is inexpedient to legislator
representative toner moves inexpedient
to legislator on house 175 is there a
second representative would seconds is
there discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
175 are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role on
the motion of inex speeding to legislate
on House Bill 175
representative qua yes representative
pom o Brian yes representative Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey buia yep representative
C yes representative kovski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane no representative Ward no
representative Gilmore no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Grill no representative
wilham yes representative Newsome
no and chairman
Barry chair votes
yes you got representative wihelm voting
yes oh no I was this is my total yeah he
voted yes oh he did he did willham yes
oh I'm sorry that's that's why my head
popped up like
breaking up now I have to do
math thanks representative um so with
that the motion of inexpedient to
legislate carries on a vote of 11
to7 um representative toner you will be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane who will be
responsible for my Minority Report
representative Mirad will be responsible
for Minority Report uh there will be uh
we're going to close the executive
session for house for 175 there will be
no more votes today uh we will if we
have time discuss some of the other
bills on there but there will be no more
votes today so if any members needing to
depart um May do so you don't have to
worry about there being a vote um thank
you so much we're going to leave
executive session and we're going to go
back into public hearings I'm going to
open up the public hearing on House Bill
154 and recognize representative C for
the purpose of introduction
reprentative C you ready to rock yes uh
thank you Mr chairman and uh members of
the House election law committee I'm
representative Alvin C of lden
representing eight towns in marac County
District
26 I'm here today to introduce House
Bill 154 an act enabling voters to
request to have their ballots hand
counted this bill is quite
straightforward in that it makes it
clear that the legislature allows for
some individual voters to choose to have
their ballot to be hand counted and that
they can do so without forcing an
overvote for the ballot counting device
to
reject resulting in a hand-counted
ballot
anyway there was some confusion at last
state election that when a memo was sent
to the moderators across the state from
the uh attorney general and Secretary of
State uh saying that the moderators
would have to take names and Report uh
those who asked to have their ballot
hand counted so this is to clarify that
the um that it is a permissible thing
for people to
do
um and I think for considering this bill
and I have I'll take questions if there
are any are there questions from the
committee representative Bay thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so would this uh request also
be available for uh those who requested
absentee ballots and how would they do
that uh thank you for the question for
absentee ballots
um there is not a provision for doing
that so
um and that's not included in this bill
I did not consider that uh possibility
normally those ballots would just be uh
when they process them just fed through
the machine unless there is happens to
be an overvote on them in which case
they would have to be put in the
auxiliary compartment for hand counting
later follow up yeah most do you think
that should also that provision should
also be available for those who vote
both
absentee I don't know that it's really
that necessary because I think the
people who are likely to be the ones
asking to have their ballot handc
counted are also likely to be people who
would be in person voters but there's no
reason not to
consider um having a provision
unfortunately you'd have to change
the
um absentee ballot application
and maybe some other provisions of law
to be able to accommodate
that further questions from the
committee representative
flan are are you familiar with the
numerous studies that have been done
that hand counting is actually more
subject to error than machine counting I
haven't necessarily uh seen all the
studies but having uh been a uh an
observer at recounts on quite a few uh
different recount sessions now uh I'm
quite familiar that the hand count towns
usually have more errors than the
machine count towns and could I have a
followup yeah as no one else has one
yeah follow uh are you concerned at all
that this might slow down getting
results if if a lot of people do this
particularly in towns like Manchester or
uh I guess Dairy is town uh it could
really slow down
results it it can slow things down but I
think it slows it down even more when
people uh deliberately put an overvote
on their ballot so then uh in the
process of going through because the
overv vote ballots have to be handc
counted anyway that's a separate
provision uh it
just uh it about all it really shows is
that there are some people who don't
like the idea of using
machines further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up is I'm having trouble reading the
last name but
John cine I give about the as someone
who also has not great handwriting I I I
I you I do I mean if you saw mine you
would understand that that was not meant
with with uh any sort of criticism you
said Co cawthorne
can you spell it for me just real
fast thank
you okay first thing you have to is
press the button in front of you there
you go and hold it down that nope you
just you let it go fine and and we will
be gentle I promise okay so I've never
testified in front of a committee before
so I'm new at this my name is John KRON
I'm the moderator for w N9 and ASA I'm
also a senior software analyst for a
software company I'm testifying support
of this bill because as moderator um
I've seen an increase I've presided over
three elections since I was elected and
there's an increasingly large portion of
the population in my experience that
doesn't trust our elections doesn't
trust the machines and they want their
ballots hand counted it's because they
believe the human interaction with the
ballot would be more thorough than the
machine interaction with the ballot
which they feel as though the machine is
not always accurate as far as Contin
these at the end of the night there's
such a small portion of these ballots
maybe 10 15 20 and we have to count the
uaba ballots to put in hands slaught
anyways this is no burden on workers
it's no burden on the election it
doesn't take any longer I don't know how
many of you are familiar with the
election process as it is but we count
all the ballots before the election and
on Election night we take them all out
of the tabulator we count them all again
so we're counting 5,500 ballots at least
in the last election of my ward anyways
so if this increases voter confidence
that their vote is actually being
counted as the way they intended and
doesn't put any strain on my election
workers I see no problem with this bill
whatsoever and I think I would encourage
it okay uh will you be taking questions
from the committee yes okay are there
questions from the
committee okay oh yes representative P
O'Brien where dairy is a town yeah
that's right are you aware of of any
people or have you heard that people are
are over voting purposefully so that
their ballot will be counted have you
heard that I have not heard of that
because the machine rejects the
overvotes so at least in Nashville the
tabulators we're using if there's an
overvote it's rejected so we don't
accept overvotes they get that that
ballots voided and they get another
ballot further questions from the
committee representative Wei yeah just a
a quick question along the lines of
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh representative C
mentioned a memorandum that came from
the state did did you as a moderator in
Nashwood receive such a memorandum yes I
received a memorandum and I refused to
comply with it we actually uh the ward
Clerk and my Emily ad seak my w clerk
confronted people that wanted their
encountered and wanted to take their
information report them I prevented her
from doing that informed everyone in my
ward that at least in ward nine we're
not going to uh conformed to that order
by the Secretary of State this is not
Nazi Germany this is United States we
should not be taking people's
information who just want to vote so we
did receive that yes but I refus to
comply
okay representative n thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question um back to the overvote issue
when there's an overvote on One race out
of many does it reject the entire Ballot
or does it count all of those others
races where there's no overvote it
rejects the ballot in its entirety and
we have to void the ballot and give the
voter a new
ballot so if there's three um just say
it says there's five candidates pick two
and they pick three the ballots rejected
so that means that ballot is not counted
at all no race in that ballot has
counted it never goes through the
tabulator it's rejected back to us and
it says so on the readout of the
tabulator further questions from the
committee see none thank you can I have
one other comment about the over thing I
think what might be confusing here is
that there's writing campaigns to make
sure that we there votes are handc
counted as well so people will fill in
right in B right in spots because those
are hand counted in every single
election because the machine can't read
them so that might be what's actually
occurring we have a lot of right in
votes um further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um last
up is Al brandano um representative
gusovsky if you could grab that blue
sheet for me that'd be
great Alber Deno Kensington New
Hampshire uh I'm in support of this bill
uh one to clarify a point today about uh
hand count um there is no peir review St
it's really dangerous when people make
statements without a peer- review study
uh on this subject matter so if we're
going to accuse that one system is
better than another it should be
peer-reviewed and you should have the
study so we all can understand what
you're referring to uh secondly the
Constitution calls for accuracy not
efficiency the New Hampshire
Constitution nor the US Constitution
says something must be done within a
certain period of time represent see if
you guys can take your conversation
outside you guys low rumbling voices we
can't hear thank you um restart your
stle Mr uh Brandon I apologize thank you
sir um the Constitution calls for
accuracy not efficiency we get uh pushed
away from what our duty is uh especially
Swan o of Duty that you swear to to
defend the Constitution uh and in this
case uh it's accuracy not efficiency um
the third part is intimidation I can
tell you about intimidation because one
my town in Kensington the moderator
chose to put people or threaten people
not threaten I shouldn't say that uh but
the the letter from the moderate the
letter from the Secretary of State and
the Attorney General was virtually
intimidation it was put out two days
before it was a memo and it said if you
have your vote hand counted you can do
it the moderator should allow it but if
you do allow it you're going to be put
on a list now that to me what list where
does it go no one knows a memo is not a
point of law a memo is just a memo so
it's shameful that they use that tactic
but a lot of people were frightened and
referred to and what they did is they
did what uh the moderator behind me just
said is they wrote in their ballots they
put in people's names and it got hand
counted anyway because they were afraid
of being put on the
list I had 91 a with another person the
Attorney General's office to find out
how many people were on the list and to
the best of my knowledge it looks like
at the time we did it was 25 to 28
people so this is really quite a
shameful event and we should be ashamed
of ourselves for intimidating
voters
uh and I'll take any questions okay are
there questions from the committee
representative
Grill um in terms of the the memo that
was issued are you aware of any uh Court
challenges uh it seems to me that that
would violate voter privacy if you have
a town of so many and only there believe
it or not I don't we don't know why it
was done that way but it was done that
way it's it's public knowledge and it's
in the evidence and there are people who
are moving towards a lawsuit in my
understanding against the Secretary of
State and this is why and the Attorney
General this is why having something
like this so people aren't intimidated
and can't be intimidated and like I say
it's a small number of people but it you
know if we allow students to vote with
5-year-old IDs and we allow uh you know
people who are residents but aren't
residents and we allow all these things
what's wrong with allowing someone to
have their vote handc counted it and
like I said there's an alternative way
to do it by handwriting but that's
really puts more work on the
moderators further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um I
don't think I have any more pink cards
for this bill um on the blue sheet there
was one in support one against and what
was the bill number one more time for me
uh4 154 and then online on what on sell
714 my
apologies no no no no that's for me as
I'm on 114 uh online there were 16 in
support 146
opposed
um and once again fluide
um with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 154 and I I
guess I apologize for the scheduling ER
I guess I 15 minutes to kill so that's
hasn't happened in a minute um I don't
let's finish up our executive session
like I said there's no more votes um so
uh our going to reopen 423 does anybody
else have the any any more having heard
what everybody said about the political
signs anybody have anything else they
want to aine
on we didn't get representative Grill's
thoughts oh I apologize yes
representative I am so sorry yes
representative Grill what we need from
you here is if you could write the
political sign laws in New Hampshire as
you saw fit and no one could stop you
from doing it what would you do oh
that's a scary question um I love signs
the bigger the flashier the tackier the
better put them all over the place no
I'm I'm kidding I'm kidding um I think
my concern is if we get into the realm
of a budding
um would that not
be in in effect letting one um person
who might not like a particular sign
dictate what signs are placed on public
property or State
Property oh it's it's not a yeah this is
literally your time to aine it's not a
question and answer period no iess I
guess I'm just curious about about that
side so that's my concern
um I mean signs are
our speech in my opinion and should give
people as many chances to have their
voice heard and obviously don't go
putting signs on people's private
property without permission but I think
if it's public or if it's a neighboring
property then it should be fair game in
my opinion so keep them keep the signs
coming and you couldn't be more wrong no
couldn't be
more I have I yes representative L um I
I had said I would just something about
easements um to go back to uh
representative nome's analogy um if you
have a bundle of sticks when you give
somebody an easement you're giving them
one of your sticks and so depending on
what the easement agreement says and
that's where the state is where you get
involved with the state you may or may
not have the right to put signs up you
may or may not have the right to use
that or you may have rights to use it as
you see fit so it depends on what the
easement agreement says when whoever
granted the easement to the state or the
city for that sidewalk or that piece of
land or whatever it is is going to be
governed by the easement agreement and
so um and if there's no easement
agreement then it goes to common law and
I have no idea what that says because I
can't remember but aren't you an
attorney no I used to be an attorney you
never need legal advice don't call
that's what she's saying um further
conversations on this representative I
said we're just we're just talking here
so if you guys want to go to the
bathroom or whatever I just I want to
explore this I think I'm I think I'm
coming to an idea of what I'm going to
do but well I have a I have a further
thought in response to your preference
of no political signs on PR on public
property and I believe that was also the
preference of Representative Nome no
signs on public property at all but
except by permission of the municipality
well I I guess I'm I'm okay with it
being on State Property the way it is
now it's giving the right to control to
an private individual is where I have
problems and
I understand that my particular
situation I described that would satisfy
my concerns but Pro the the difficulty
with as everything we we do here is
having it enforced
if the state enforced that if the state
owned the property underneath its
highway right of way and enforced no
signs on state public property then that
would suit me fine so that's all I just
want to comment on that further comments
questions
concerns um okay so I think what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna draft multiple
amendments um cuz we can we can take up
multiple amendments so I think what I'm
going to do is try to divide the
question as many ways as
possible and um so like we'll do like
one like total ban we'll start with like
just towns like just towns so I'll bring
up one that is just total ban in towns
and towns can allow it where they want
to allow it and we can vote on that how
we want and if it fails it fails and
it's adopted it's adopted um and then
I'll think I'll do one with State uh
right of
ways where the a property owner can put
it up so long as it doesn't interfere
with traffic um but no one else can and
then I'll do one with an
adjoiner however I'm going to craft that
that'll be a fun one to craft by the way
that'll be a real fun one to craft um
but basically what I'm saying is I think
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
to chop it up like three ways four ways
if I can figure fig it out and just let
the committee
vote and if it all fails we change
nothing and if something passes we go
with that route um because I think it's
safe to
say there's not a partisan issue unlik
most things in election law it doesn't
appear to be that there's one side
advocating for the other right is that
is that a fair statement it's kind of
all over the place you've got Grill over
there wants the more signs me with the
no signs
um so um I guess that's not a good
example how about I want the no signs
and Clayton represented wood wants all
the signs so there you go that's a
better example um so I think that's what
I will do on that does anybody else have
a better idea of how to handle
that yeah yeah towns and cities together
yeah the local the county I'll do County
too I'll talk I'll toss County in there
too um so does anybody does anybody have
a better idea than that of a way to
handle that and I guess I I dare say a
democratic
process I was going to say just start
with an itl yeah yeah you just kill well
I I don't want to do that cuz then I
wouldn't have killed the I would I
wouldn't have killed the the one that is
actually probably be more than more more
relevant um that was 365 I think right
was the first one um so no I I would
rather just vote I think what I'm going
do is I'm going to take like 365 tried
to do slam it onto this change the
language in here about a butter to ad
joiners like that'll be an amendment
changing the budding language to ad
joining language I think I do think
that's a better term
joint yeah I think that's I think that's
a better ter like regardless I think
like like there's something that could
actually happen like just the adjoining
go AB budding going to ad joining could
be a thing that happens um and then just
work from there and who knows like you
know maybe it all goes down and flames
and then probably goes to the floor and
just gets eviscerated on a bipartisan
vote it'll be hilarious
but so is anybody yes out representative
C uh two things one you may want to uh
consider areas along highways that are
uh apparently unimproved
properties uh you may not know who it
belongs to but it's just Woods or Farm
fields or something like that but the
what I was going to uh suggest was
before you get OS all tied up uh just
bring in
proposed uh proposals for LS uh for
amendments and then we can do that
that's just a suggestion yes well
they're going to have two weeks because
we're not going to be voting at all next
week um so justway there's no votes next
week um just hearings because it's
school vacation weeks next week right so
there will be only hearings next week so
if you're out you're out um and if you
need a question definitely definitely
don't do what representative Mirad did
and send it in real
fast um if you're gonna send the if
you're G to send the text message don't
be don't wave the phone I'm just saying
like it's too E I don't care don't be
obvious U it was more I was more
offended at the obvious nature of it
than anything um
so yeah so so there's no votes next week
um so I guess I guess that that's my
thing is it's like I don't know if I'll
have time after that to grab their
amendments but OLS will have two weeks
to put together amendments
um we've got seven more minutes is there
any updates out of the sub commmittee
out of the other than the bill we uh
killed uh no we we looked we tried to
look at uh
6543 all the bills pertaining to 65413
we read through the very ious topics and
we looked at the um there are four bills
pertaining to 65413 we had some
discussions we ended up killing that one
and um you know we also received a memo
from uh Mr Allen regarding a number of
court cases so we'll be discussing those
in this
upcoming uh subcommittee meeting
okay I think secretary scanlan's coming
this week to talk to us we will be
uh joined by secretary scanland and um
by um
Henry Clement totz Clement totz um the
American civil liberties Union yes sir
so uh we're looking forward to hearing
their testimonies on this subject matter
okay awesome all right well with that um
I'm going to close the executive session
on House Bill
423 uh I'm going to open the executive
session session for 154 we are recessing
this I'm trying to get an amendment in
but I can't ever find chance to file it
but what I'm going to do just for
situational awareness I don't think the
ranking member is going to love this but
that's what I'm going to do um is I'm
going to uh I'm going to switch it over
to a report that comes out uh 60 days
out of the election accessible by the
town because that's how we do lists most
of these most of these we have yet to
allow the
general public to access the Statewide
voter file um we allow candidates to do
we allow Statewide candids do it we
allow the parties to do it but we've
never allowed an individual to go in and
do it so I I personally just don't want
to start that precedent um so I'm going
to basically take their
report shove it down to the town level
um and then uh release the actual
address but I I haven't decided yet if
I'm going to have it tied to the voter
or not um but I do think I I do want
that address out
there 60 days after the election okay so
we're not talking about 158 right thank
you okay yes we're talking about 158
just wasn't I didn't I didn't switch
gear F yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah I just
wanted to let you know that like that
that's what I'm I'm going to file
something along those lines I just
haven't had the chance to do it yet cuz
as you can tell by me talking out loud
I'm still on my brain kind of sorting it
um but that's that's why we're not
voting on that today so anyways um
that's what I'm doing there any other
comments on
158 all right I'm going to recess 158
formally um and then I'll open 684 and
immediately recess 684 because it's in
the possession of the subcommittee so
that's all for the execs uh we've
got four minutes so do what you want
well the committee will stand in recess
till
2:30
e
e e
okay it's 2:30 going to open up the
public hearing for House Bill
693 and recognize representative pelli
for the purpose of introduction uh 293
relative to ballot counting procedures
and permitting the hand counting of
ballots repres representative Pell
welcome thank you
okay good afternoon members of the
election law committee for the record
I'm representative Susan portelli
Rockingham District 19 Hampton Falls and
Kensington thank you for hearing my
testimony on HB 693 to permit hand
counting of ballots and to conduct a
supplemental count of ballots at the
discretion of the selectman or the town
clerk the first objective of this bill
is to permit a voter to present their
ballot to the moderator for hand
counting we just heard discussion on hb1
154 to permit hand counting of ballots
so I will reiterate the need for
consistency through throughout the state
to allow this process without the use of
last minute memos from the Secretary of
State or the attorney general and these
memos are not laws but process
suggestions many towns exclusively hand
Count Their ballots such as Southampton
or as we all know dicksville Notch and
of course our original New Hampshire
Constitution provided for the hand
counting of ballots so this is just
simply making it very consistent that
cities or towns are allowed to have
their voters as defined in the con
Constitution hand Count Their
ballots the other objective of this bill
has two parts the first is enabling
legislation to allow Selectmen or the
town clerk at their discretion to
conduct a supplemental hand count of a
specific race to confirm the
results a supplemental count is simply a
second count before certification
it is not an audit or recount these two
processes have very specific rules and
these uh Audits and recounts U happen
after the results are
announced this enabling legislation will
allow Selectmen or town clerks to
conduct this supplemental hand count of
ballots at their discretion or for
ballots not processed through a voting
machine or counted from a machine that
may have failed during the voting period
in the recent past Selectmen and town
clerks were discouraged or
preventing from performing this uh
discretionary supplemental hand count of
a specific election race to cross check
and validate machine counts and this
happened days before an election through
the use of these arbitrary memos from
the Secretary of State or attorney
general so the purpose of this bill is
to codify the practice for Selectmen or
town or city officials the ab the
ability to conduct at their discretion
this supplemental hand count for a
specific race just to confirm the
election results without these
lastminute advisory rules from the
executive or the judicial
branch our New Hampshire constitution in
part two Article 2 and you could see my
well-worn copy is very specific about
allowing Selectmen to witness the count
of votes with the Town Clerk and the
moderator is responsible for counting
the votes in
elections in summary article 32 states
that the Selectmen
whose Duty it shall be to attend an open
meeting receive the votes of all the
inhabitants of such towns and Wards
present and shall in said meetings in
the presence of the said Selectmen and
of the town or city clerk in said
meetings sort and count the said votes
and make a public declaration thereof
you got to love the writers of this
thing because they really thought
through it it um and then of course they
have a a responsibility to name every
person voted voting and count the number
of votes for each person so simply
stated this bill will provide a
consistent framework for use throughout
the state for hand counting and
supplemental counting of votes as
defined in our New Hampshire
constitution in part two article 32
without confusing last minute directives
from the Secretary of State or attorney
general thank
you okay we'll be taking questions from
the committee are there questions from
the
committee um we'll start we'll go right
to left to representative C thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question
um I was very concerned about
online can you talk in on the mic just a
little more I'm having trouble hearing
you
I'm having trouble hearing you know
people at home are um on the line uh uh
well on on the last paragraph beginning
on
19 um it gives the U uh Clerk or
selectman their discretion and then it
lists three different things one of
those the second one is the hand count
ballots that were not processed through
a voting
machine um and my concern is because you
a votes and also overvotes don't go
through there but we need to count all
ballots should that not have been in
there well this is for the supplemental
count so the selectman could say for a
specific race let's count all of the
ballots hand count all of the ballots so
we can compare the hand count of a
specific race versus whatever the
machine and the other uh processes said
so it's just a double check before the
vote is certified that's all that a
supplemental count is and some towns do
this but unfortunately in the last
election there was some very confusing
Direction about not allowing certain uh
moderators to use this process so it's
just a process of a checkin
balance okay I I found it a little
confusing reading but anyway got got do
a followup if you're going to do if you
believe I found it confusing um
representative
Lane I are you do you know the reason
why this Memo from the Secretary of
State came out I mean I I I'm not aware
of it so I I really don't know much
about that memo so I represent Hampton
Falls in Kensington and yes in
Kensington the uh moderator did rece and
moderators received this um memo and I
did see it in the town of Kensington
that I represent and it was very
confusing because it again it's not law
it was just a directive about hand
counts and preventing supplemental
counts and it got to be very confusing
for um many moderators because it's not
a consistent practice throughout the
state further questions from the
committee represent Nome thank you and
thank you for taking the question um as
you noted in your testimony we heard a
bill earlier to allow for the voter to
request hand counting and I notice that
your bill amends a different section of
the rsas do we need to amend it in both
sections or would only one spot be
sufficient I will double check with OS I
noted I asked them about this before
they um actually drafted the bill and
they I was advised this is the section
but obviously they're two bills asking
for the same thing so we'll have to
figure out how to um how how to make
sure that it makes sense and may have a
followup yes um thank you and through
this process um I believe you said it
was the moderator whose responsibility
it is to announce the total
votes what happens then if any of these
supplemental things come comes up with a
different result who's who say it's the
the according to what I understand it's
the moderator that will have to um
review the counts from from for the for
the specific race and make sure that
everything comes out even they've got to
balance it
out further questions from the committee
representative we thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so this
is uh um this is not a recount it's not
an audit it is simply kind of a quality
control check on the quantity of ballots
that have been accumulated during that
election process um has this practice
been in place before yes many towns
currently employ this and uh we just
want to make sure that it it is um a
consistent process throughout the state
so that there's no confusion on Election
Day
further questions from the
committee representative
Gilmore you know I've been a moderator
for over 12 years and I've never heard
of this but my real question is when
you're doing a supplemental hand count
are you counting every ballot for that
race for a particular race correct just
to make sure that they um match what the
tape results would be you know in these
presidential elections I'm going home at
2 a.m. I can't imag follow the
representative Gilmore no question thank
you
okay it's not it's not every race it is
at the discretion of you know the town
clerk or
um Selectmen for a specific
race all right further questions from
the committee um thank you so much just
so everybody knows I did just send in an
email to the Secretary of State and I
copied the ranking member of the vice
chairman for to get a copy of memo uh so
if we get a copy of the memo I'll
distribute it to the um Committee in a
in a BCC email to avoid a conversation
um but I think it's I think there's
enough questions around this memo that
we should probably lay eyes on it um La
I only have one pink card um so it's a
albrand
Dono
uh not that I see so can you fill out
another one for me Mr
cine Kon
so I thought that's what I said did I
not I don't know why I missed
that uh what is it is it written
testimony or is it stuff you're going to
reference that's fine we have plenty of
time so it's fine we're towards the end
of the
day e
okay
oh late
entry
yeah whenever you're
ready thank you very much uh Al brand
Dano Kensington New Hampshire um I'm I'm
here in support of this bill um first of
all I want to make perfectly clear um if
you look at uh unfortunately for the
reference I didn't have the 2025 manual
so it is the same on page four I want to
point out to you Roman numeral 4 it's
the same in the 2025 26 manual the
bottom part I'm not going to read it to
you but what it basically says if
there's ever a conflict in the manual in
the policy and procedure manual this
between the Secretary of State and a
moderate Ator or the town the town
attorney is the person who makes the
decision the point I'm I'm making here
is the moderator in the town is
responsible for all
elections this document clearly states
that who who is responsible so the
moderator is the responsible party the
second part I gave you is um the
Constitution if you look at it's part
two article 32 it's really specific once
again 1784 there was no electricity so
Hand counting was you know that was it
and uh and on this case if you look at
it the moderator will sort and count the
votes very important that's what he does
the Selectmen in the town clerks act as
the um eyes the witnesses they're the
ones who sign off at the end of the
night that the election was conducted
correctly just like now when they sign
off uh at at the end of the night the
select M Town Clerk as well as the
moderator what happened was when we
allowed the election to be done by a
machine constitutionally we didn't
follow up with the responsibility of the
Selectmen and the town clerks they're
always the responsible party to verify
the election before it happen so that's
why I'm suppored this bill it allows
them if there's something wrong in the
election process allows the selectman
and the town clerk to say to the
moderator hey wait a minute let's do a
secondary count which has been it's
happened in the state from 2014 on I
have it here I'll leave it up on the
message and it's from uh I'll say it uh
it was uh the moderators may use this
discretion as to whether or not they
will conduct such a count on Election
night if they decide to conduct a second
count on Election night they should have
a good reason for doing so moderators do
not need the cond do not need to conduct
such a second count just because some
member of the public requested one it's
really important so we all understand we
want to give that Authority Constitution
Authority back to them they're not aware
of it most Mo most Selectmen and town
clerks are not aware of it we're just
caught bringing this back into the
Constitution um and finally uh hb1 154
is really important um and and um
chairman of this committee had quite a
hand in structuring it it was a non-gain
healthc care bill
that ended up being coming election law
22 election Law changes were put into a
non- Germain um election um sorry a uh
healthc care bill but I point out to you
on page five if you look at page 5 even
in hb1 154 it
recognizes it's to follow the directions
of the moderator you can put it in the
machine or follow the directions of the
moderator so this
Bill what it does it codifies us it
gives us Authority it it it brings us
back to the Constitution and I'm support
of it thank
you okay will you be taking questions
please are there questions from the
committee saying none thank you uh last
up is John cin
so proceed whenever I'm ready Mr Barry
absolutely so hello again committee
members thank you for uh taking my
testimony so again I'm John KRON I'm the
net moderator for w n Nashua I'm also a
senior systems analyst for a software
company which is important to the
conversation because one thing you
should all understand if you don't
understand is that if a machine can be
programmed to do good a machine can be
programmed to do bad a machine can also
malfunction and a machine can have bugs
so the tabulators and N are they um lauo
tabulators but they're programmed so
they're dependent upon who's doing the
programming so the reason parallel hand
counts are or supplemental hand counts
were important and they were started
historically by w w moderator Wally Fri
of Danville is that allows a moderator
to know that the machines are actually
working correctly because the moderators
are not involved in the testing of the
machines the testing of the machines
happens prior to the moderators
receiving them on Election Day and all
we see is that there's evidence that the
machine was tested the city clerk signed
off that it's working properly but we
have no idea that it is working properly
so Wally fly Fri came up with a
supplemental or parallel hand count so
that he could hand count the races and
compare those results to what the
machines were actually
saying so that's why the supplemental
parallel handc counts are important
because as I said as moderator people
are increasing not trusting of our
voting systems and that they know the
machines can be messed with look up
Harry hsty in the in the tabulator as
anyone can see that on YouTube the
second part of this is the Secretary of
State and the Attorney General since
2016 have been usurping the authority of
the moderators and threatening and
intimidating moderators not to perform
their constitutional duties this
happened to me in November 5th 2024 I
was going to perform a parallel
supplemental hand count of the
governor's race I had my um moderator
Pro and one of the slackman all set to
do that we had four teams of two to
count all the votes and uh my ward clerk
called the attorney general on me and
reported me that I was doing something
that was illegal I got on a phone with
Dick Tracy from the Attorney General's
office who threatened with having me
arrested and for committing a crime
violating election law that I did not
have the authority to count the votes as
I saw I saw fit so for personal reasons
and at the end of a 20-hour day I
decided to tell my team count them as
they normally would and Mr Tracy told me
that if we put the ballots in one pile
it's legal if we put the ballots in two
or more piles it's illegal because
that's an audit now I'd also like to
refer you all to the opinion of the
justices 53n 640 and and and it was
decided in 1873 by the new Hamp Supreme
Court of New Hampshire which recognizes
the Constitution gives the moderated
authority to govern the election the
secretary of state does not have the
city clerks doesn't have the authority
to go the election the Attorney General
does not have the authority the
moderator has that Authority the
moderator the justic has also said in
any case to which these constitutional
Provisions are applicable they are the
controlling and supreme law of the state
and by the statute first cited they're
made applicable to representes in Con in
Congress the Constitution and these
statutes are too explicit to leave any
doubt in the minds of the general public
of the duty of the moderator to count
the votes make a public declaration
thereof it furthermore says that if
there's a problem on Election night the
best way to correct that problem is with
the moderator on election tonight not
waiting until the secretary of state
does a
recount so you may not know this but as
I said my prior testimony before every
election I get a team to go to City Hall
we all volunteer and we count the number
of ballots we receive from the Secretary
of State to say this 5,500 he says it we
we count that 5,500 quite often it's not
accurate so it could be 5,600 at the end
of ele every election night we open up
tabulator we take out all those ballots
and put them on tables and we pile them
in piles and we count them anyways so
the hand count is happening in every
single election as a matter of course
now all we're asking in this bill is
that the attorney general and the
Secretary of State stop interfering with
the moderator if he wants to do this
process and then we add this duty to the
selectman in town clerk if they choose
to do so so it's pretty simple in the in
the governor's race which I was going to
supplemental hand count I would have
instructed my election workers to put
the aot ballots in one pile the Craig
ballots in another pile we would then
count them add up the total of those
piles to make sure we end up with the
same amount of bar ballots and then
Compare the aot numbers to the print out
of the tape and compare the Craig
numbers to the print out of the tape to
make sure that it was accurate Hava the
federal law says that our elections are
in no trust system that means Dan hilly
signed off that the machine is working
but I can't trust him I have to test
that in some manner so when I went to
test that an election night I was
threatened with committing a crime so
you cannot operate as a moderator under
these conditions particularly when the
Secretary of State talks like he is the
force of law you follows his
instructions and if you are wrong he
says it's your fault but if you are
right he says you don't have the power
and if you refer to page four of that
election procedure manual it says right
there this is not the law this is the
opinion of the Secretary of State and I
can tell you as a citizen who's just
trying to do a good job at the other end
of the phone on from the attorney
general at a call at the end of election
night is's no place that you want to be
that's why I'm here because we have this
power anyways the legislature needs to
remind the powers that be the moderators
at their discretion can do these hand
counts they should not be interfered
with I'll take any questions okay are
there questions from the committee
representative
Lane thank you for taking my question um
you mentioned a a Supreme Court case yes
I can give this to you I can you talk
very quickly so I couldn't jot it down
so I'm so sorry I'm a little bit nervous
well you're doing a great job so don't
so the the opinion of the justices 53n
640 nh1
1873 was a case in which the city clerk
reported an an incorrection invalid vote
number okay so the purpose of the case
was to correct who had the authority to
adjust that incorrect count and did the
city clerk or the town clerk have the
authority to override the moderator and
the justice has said no that the city
clerk cannot correct a mistake by the
moderator the Selectmen uh during the
election I can do that but I will submit
this for everyone to read
further questions representative Newsome
thank you thank you for taking the
question um I was a little confused by
your testimony it
seemed to say at one point that the
machines are tested before the election
but then you said they weren't tested
before the election what I'm saying is
LHS systems uh owns the proprietary
software for the tabulators at least for
ASA so LHS systems as far as I
understand the process is that prior to
the election the city clerk Dan Haley
very good man he and LHS systems test
the machines to make sure they're
accurate in other words I think they run
like 50 ballots through look at the tape
and make sure it says 50 ballots so an
election morning I Reed the tabulator
and it's signed off by danan Healey that
it's working properly all I do is sign
that yeah that's the evidence that's
working properly but I have no evidence
that it's working I didn't do the test
and if you look at look up Harry Hy on
YouTube you can see how easy it is to
manipulate the memory cards in these
machines so I think I'm answering your
question but I don't do the test
personally as the moderator I just sign
off that it was
tested I just wanted to confirm that yes
you answered the question that the
moderator for the city is the one doing
that test no the city clerk and LHS
systems City cler LHS systems does test
city clerk thank you and quick followup
though I got to go to representative
toner first he's flaged in no
problem um I just had a quick question
um so in my town uh there was a defect
in the circuitry of the bo of the of the
V voting machine on when they performed
their test the parent
test it worked and the day of the
election it didn't work and then someone
ran a circuit
board what what is your opinion of a
situation like that that occurs like in
my in my understanding there was no test
run on the second circuit
board then they should have handc
counted the entire race because you
don't know what that circuit board is
going to produce you don't know who
programmed that circuit board and like
as a senior software analyst that
circuit board could do whatever the
programmer told it to do
further questions seeing none thank you
I don't have any more pink cards should
I put this on the desk up there yes
please and then 263 uh was 10 in
supports 23
right and 236 opposed one
neutral
so what fluide I I think I did see
fluoride and yes there is there
you think you think I don't look but I
do look um on the blue sheet is one in
support one against and with that we'll
close the public hearing for House
Bill 693 and we will open the public
hearing for House Bill 274 represent
recognize our own representative Wei for
the purpose of
introduction why were they booing
representative booze I heard booze all
right
thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Bob war and have the privilege of
representing Hillsboro District 13 the
great town of
Hudson RSA 65439 currently calls for the
verification of the voter roles every 10
years in what is you euphemistically
known as the voter role Purge this
verification looks to remove voters who
have not voted in a number of Elections
or have moved but did not form but did
not inform the state or who have died by
current statute this 10-year cycle
occurs on the year ending in one most
recently 2021 famously the Great Purge
of 2021 removed approximately a quarter
of a million voters from the New
Hampshire voter roles reducing the
number of Voters from approximately
1.12 million to approximately 880,000
voters by Statute the verifications
currently have a look back of a 4-year
duration whereby if the voter has been
active in any local primary or general
election they are not removed from the
voter roles in 2024 I observed the
working sessions of the supervisor of
the checklist for my local town of
Hudson in the three short years since
the 2021 Purge Hudson has had over 900
people who could be potentially purged
from the current voter roles in the 2024
general election Hudson saw nearly
15,000 people voting so in rough figures
approximately 6% of the voter roles were
effective that's a ma massive amount of
work to deal with uh 900 letters along
with u follow-up letters and so on so
people are uh heading to New Hampshire
to take advantage of the many freedoms
to Live Free or Die state offers perhaps
they are simply fleeing the People's
Republic of Massachusetts regardless of
their motivations New Hampshire is
experiencing a steady growth rate
particularly in the southern areas
therefore it seems appropriate to
decrease the interval in which voter
verification are done to compensate for
this increased frequency the bill also
extends the look back on voter activity
from a 4-year to a 5-year duration this
allows a look back to include at least
one presidential general election which
of course is the election having the
greatest voter turnout this increased
frequency of verification along with the
increased look back duration will result
in at least three benefits one more
accurate checklist who wouldn't want
that uh Second lower and less stressful
workloads for the supervisors of the
checklist that is the ongoing annual
performance of the voter verification
will be far less stressful than the
massive undertaking required when the
verification is only performed every 10
years and three more consistency in the
voter verification practice by
performing this verification annually
the supervisors of the checklist will be
more readily familiar with the process
and should have an easier time
completing the verific verification task
I also note that uh with the bill we
heard earlier HB 341 if that's taking
care of the address changes with the
national change of address information
then this verification would address
voters who have died or who have been
inactive and so uh I think the two bills
in tandem would certainly give us
extremely accurate checklists I would be
glad to try and answer any questions the
committee may have are there questions
from the committee representative Lane I
was I was I just knew just knew you just
knew I I didn't even I I I I didn't see
you raise your hand honestly I
just so I seem to have misplaced my copy
of the bill but um that's okay I've
already discussed it a little bit with
representative uh weie um this is uh
similar to a bill that we saw last year
uh HB
1369 and in that bill uh it was a review
every four years not annually and
then it looked back over six years and
because of that we were able to capture
two presidential elections so for
instance if you missed one there was a
second one so in order to have gotten
bumped off the roles you would have had
to have missed two presidential
elections so I guess I would just like
you to speak to why now only one because
whether we like it or not
as you indicated that's when most we get
more votes more voters yeah I can't
speak for all areas but certainly we see
almost a three times uh the local
election turnout for voter election uh
in Hudson I think generally the voting
populace within New Hampshire is
energized for the uh presidential races
and therefore um very few people miss it
and so we and usually the ones who miss
it would would uh certainly be able to
when they receive a letter uh from the
supervisor the checklist explained why
they might have been in active in that
last presidential race and therefore I
think that we just need one presidential
race to look back on I don't think we
need multiple
ones
sure uh why an annual review rather than
every four years the way you had it set
up last
year it's really just uh for that
consistency and and reducing the overall
workload year-to-year um so it's like
dollar cost averaging for investment you
know this is just consistently doing
this practice year after year after year
it it keeps the the uh voter
checklists as accurate as possible in in
between the national change of address
uh database information as well as as
the ability to look for uh people who
have been inactive in the previous 5
years now as this bill would propose and
anyone who has passed on then that would
allow for very consistent and
accurate voter
checklists yes I'm so surprised you want
one more one more wow thank you anybody
else can join in
um would you be willing
[Laughter]
which I'm sorry I don't know if you I
don't know if you heard what any I did
not but that's okay I'm sure he can tell
me
later um now I lost my oh would you be
willing would you be willing to consider
looking back further to get two periods
if we're going to an annual one could we
extend it out so like last time we did
it so you could capture two or is that
just GE mathematically not possible I
haven't done the math so I don't
know I haven't done the I haven't done
the math either um I'd
be I know that there is a similar Bill
to this coming from the other side of
the wall so I would be curious as to
what their position is because we would
no doubt have
to come to some sort of mutual agreement
um I
think again I I I think the annual
verification has its benefits regardless
of the duration of the look back um
I so I I think I I might be amendable
but I I think there are F other factors
that we need to consider before we
completely move forward on an amendment
in that direction you never know what
they're going to do over there
new did you have a question okay would
you like me to text you
one further questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you um I don't think I have any more
pink cards for this does anybody else
wish to speak to this I I put down 30
ministers because I thought there would
be a parade of people like there
normally are and then I guess our
friends in the left disappointed me so
where's the love I where's the hate I
don't know it's either way it's not here
um all right with that we'll go online
maybe maybe they express themselves
online let's find out
274 or maybe it's just more fluoride who
knows yeah uh 23 in support 124
against um one neutral and yes fluoride
was
there um signed up against was uh Sarah
Bert con with the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association uh with that we stand in
recess till 320 my apologies I thought
there would have been some interest in
this bill cuz there was last year so
I'll see you guys in uh 13 minutes
that's
e
for
e e
tell
e
e e
okay last bill of the day going to
reopen the public hearings for house
election law committee going to open up
public heing for House Bill 317
preventing a supervisor of the checklist
from verifying a person's identity
without identification even if they
personally know that that person going
to recognize representative Burnham for
the purpose of
introduction thank you Mr chairman and
fellow committee members I am
representative Claudine Burnham
representing straford District 2 Milton
Rochester w
5 I'm introducing HB 317 a bill
preventing a supervisor of the checklist
and it does actually State other uh
election
officials um from verifying a person's
identity without identification even if
they personally know that person I've
actually seen this happen many times
where someone shows up without
identification and because they know
them they just kind of let them in and
that's okay apparently um
election should be a fair and equal
opportunity for every voter including
when they show their identification
regardless if they know an election
official others have shown disdain when
seeing others voting voters check in
without showing identification I've seen
that as well and um so we would just
like to um encourage consistency to all
and to make sure that every voter is
able to be verified equally and
consistently so thank you for your
consideration and I'll take any
questions okay questions from the
committee seeing none thank you next up
is Linda Bundy it's always best being
the last bill because people are just
like Let It Go just Let It Go just Let
It
Go and I'll be very
brief um chairman Barry and members of
house election law my name is Linda
Bundy and I'm from antrum I oppose HB
317 preventing a supervisor of the
checklist from verifying a person's
identity without identification even if
they personally know that person I
believe there is no need for this change
to the voting laws the people most
likely to not have their ID with them
are working people fitting in voting on
their way to or from their places of
employment elderly people or those with
disabilities
election workers take an oath at the
beginning of the day in keeping that
oath they would only verify a person's
identification if it were
true two of the Anum supervisors of the
checklist stated to me that they oppose
this bill one of them Linda Morehouse
has submitted online testimony that I
hope you will read the other supervisor
Aaron pills Martin has signed on in
opposition to this bill I ask that you
vote in expedient to legislate on HB 317
okay and you be taking questions no
thanks awesome well no complaints here
uh last up is Kaylee estadio and
representative kovski y looks like we
have a late entry are you coming in late
with the card yeah all right no last up
then um good afternoon chairman Barry
and members of the committee my name is
Kay of stadio I'm a Durham voter public
policy fellow with open democracy and I
am testifying today in opposition to HB
317 it is well known that the moderators
clerks and supervisors of New Hampshire
handle their duties with the utmost
levels of responsibility and care as
we've had the pleasure to hear this
afternoon simply put this bill implies
otherwise like many other bills this
session HB 317 provides a solution for a
problem that has yet to arise while
levels of voter fraud in the state are
minuscule those perpetrated by checklist
supervisors greeting their neighbor and
pointing them in the direction of the
polls are virtually
non-existent think of the local Grandma
who is eager to cast her vote but forgot
her driver's license at home the
disabled Community who already face
significant challenges in getting to the
polls the forgetful everyday citizen who
breathes a sigh of relief when they see
the clerk they know well working the
voter check-in table for this bill to go
into effect it would not work to prevent
fraud and let's face it those who dared
to commit voter fraud might use a fake
ID anyway rather it would disenfranchise
your hardworking community members if
the sole purpose of providing photo ID
at voter checkin is to verify identity
it is difficult to understand why the
approval of a trusted election worker
would not
suffice continually Pro poking and
prodding at the wellestablished and
efficient election processes is not
going to work to convince Granite
Staters elections are safe and secure
rather the growing perception of
constant unfounded change will lead to
the loss of confidence in the state's
electoral processes and breach vital
trust between the state and election
workers for these reasons I respectfully
urge you to vote HB 317 and expedian to
legislate and I'm open to questions if
there are are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you last up
is Jean Baris Barnes my apologies
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is CH Barn moderator we two un
conquered I've been doing this moderator
for 30 years if someone walks in without
identification the first thing I ask the
whole workers is does anyone know this
person many times they'll say yes if
they say no I have to fill it an
affidavit take the picture take a
picture of the person and then hand it
into City Hall at the end of the
night I don't give ID when I vote
I've been doing this for 30 years I've
chosen the people who are working at War
Two I think they know who I am and what
better
identification than your actual
face you want to look out a driver's
license if you want my signature I'll
give you that but I would hope that you
would vote this in expedience to
legislate thank you and I'll answer
questions are questions from the
committee yeah I got one representative
Gilmore thank you Mr chair
well as fellow
moderator what do you think
the goal of this bill is if it isn't to
prevent somebody from registering to
vote I don't think this is to register I
think this is to be on the checklist
yeah but they're talking to the
supervisor of the
checklist they their job they're not
going to see the supervisor of the
checklist I don't mean to get into a
discussion but I'm trying to work this
out that's okay it's the last one of the
day we'll let St fly they're not going
to be seeing the supervisor checklist
unless they're registering to vote right
they would have no reason to be there as
you and I both know after 40 plus years
of whatever combined um yeah I don't
know I'm just trying to find to figure
out what the supervisor of the checklist
are not allowed or not permitted to sit
as
checkin they are allowed they sit at the
table that have the new registrant
they're outside the polling place they
have to be outside the polling
place I just think the outside the guard
rail is what you mean right yeah not the
outside the polling place thank you
thank
you uh further questions from the
committee yes reprentative Bay thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question in your experience of for each
election how many of this type of Voters
uh come to your uh polling
place and what
I would say in the past 30 years or so
well it's only been a few years that
you've had to identify
yourself probably one each election the
major elections the cities and towns of
the 2600 voters I have I probably get
300 last general election I had
2,36 one person came with that ID and we
could not identify the per no one in the
room could identify the person may I
follow up yeah
so in any of those elections were there
any was there any rise where the winner
uh one by one vat no and I've never had
a recount and I've never had a
deficiency well we'll see I got news for
you let me tell you what happens when
you make that
promise representative Lane this isn't a
question but as I indicated before U
Miss Barnes is the moderator at my ward
and I'm telling you she runs a tight
sh okay um any further questions I have
some so um is Hartwood Lane in your
board I have 2600 voters but I do
remember yes okay all right so it's an
apartment complex so how would someone
be expected to know everybody coming in
and out of that how could they possibly
do that war two and conquered has during
the redistricting I lost most of the
houses I have trailer parks Condominiums
and apartments yeah so last election I
had 342 new
voters so um follow if you may so these
when you have that more densely packed
areas and you move to apartments and
condos forms of housing that tend to be
more
transient you have more people coming
through that your team you and your team
can't know just by virtue of you said
you have 314 so there's that's a lot of
new faces to possibly know so if those
314 people none of them showed ID what
would happen
they would I would take their picture
there's an affidavit yeah that I have to
fill out they have to sign and I take
their picture and I staple it to the
affidavit and it goes to City Hall okay
all right any other
questions thank you that's it uh we
don't have anything I don't have any do
we have a blue sheet or anything like
that has come
up it's oh yeah it's blank okay um and
then and this is Bill
uhoh is this the
memo this is that a is that an envelope
of
cash the late
entry it is the memo all right thank you
uh awesome um it is the memo I asked for
thank you Mr secretary it's not an
envelope of cash unfortunately um online
there was 14 in support 260 opposed zero
neutral um I don't have any more
business today so the committee will uh
we will reconvene next uh we're going to
close that public hearing 3117 uh there
will be there will be hearings next week
but there will be no votes so ranking
member and vice chairman please do not
ask your relative uh partisan offices to
get subs there will be no votes I will
not be um noticing the standard
executive language so there's not going
to even be discussions it's going to be
straight up hearings and go home okay so
uh that I hope you all enjoy I'll see
you on Thursday hope you all enjoy your
school vacation for those indulging um
and we will be back in two weeks for
votes and sessions so see you then